[Laughter]
hey everybody it's friday night yeah
jenny's making me work
i'm not making you i just said we didn't
have to do it
you said that you were all right
yeah i'm all right
you'll live i've been [ __ ] sick yeah
you've been sleeping for like two days i
slept like two days i feel like i'm sore
as [ __ ] it's like somebody's beating me
up with a baseball bat
taking it [ __ ] wasn't me madison
taking uh
all kinds of [ __ ]
it doesn't seem to be helping though i
was injecting steroids and everything
even that [ __ ] i remember [ __ ]
horse dewormer take that out i was he
ate some more of that today i don't
think it's helping
anything man
[ __ ] uh
although i'm better than it was
yesterday
well yeah that's how it used to be i
could walk now i was so [ __ ] sore i
could barely walk up and down the stairs
and i couldn't even yeah yesterday he
couldn't even go up and down the stairs
he was just kind of like oh he was all
like dizzy and everything to give her
peace i was camping out in the [ __ ]
man cave sleeping on the floor my
[ __ ] army gear and [ __ ] and i had to
get up to take a leak and i just could
only roll over and i was trying to push
them stand up and i couldn't get up i
was going to [ __ ] it so i'll roll over
again and try it again and then i'll
[ __ ] it then i rolled over again i just
rolling out in the middle of the [ __ ]
floor and i was trying to see it really
wrong yeah i kept rolling trying trying
to get an angle on something trying to
try to pull myself up
man i just didn't have enough [ __ ]
strength to get up everything was just
sore and pookie's watching me [ __ ] are
you doing yeah you know what i mean i
finally was in like cookie does she just
like looks at you like what are you even
doing
it feels like you know when you're when
you uh when you wake up too soon and you
can't move or like if uh
if your arm goes or your legs go to
sleep you try to stand up and you can't
walk it feels like that
it's not as bad as it was though
i don't think i've ever had that yeah
yeah i thought i thought my whole
[ __ ] central nervous system was being
oscar said yes that's definitely covered
that's what i thought that you think
it's all right i kicked his ass no you
don't is he you're leaving like whining
and sleeping all day what are you
talking about yeah no it was worse
yesterday well yeah like i said it was
like much worse yesterday
than the um maybe
yeah
no i know
i know i know when i'm winning but you
were kind of like you're like rolling
around
yeah i had to roll and try to get onto
something and try to pry myself up
but i don't have much furniture in there
so i had to keep rolling i rolled over a
little bit more and i tried to
reposition my hands my legs to try to
lever myself up off the ground and [ __ ]
and try to grab onto things you
know it's like that you know
i kind of wish i'd seen that yeah
it was like four o'clock in the morning
i'm like i gotta take a piss man come on
it's four i was kind i woke up at about
four o'clock because i usually wake up
about four o'clock in the morning
because yeah i mean i fell asleep pretty
early too but like i usually fall asleep
early because i get up early yeah like i
usually get up between 6 30 and 7. so
usually by the time 10 10 30 rolls
around i'm like watching something on tv
and i'm like
you know i'm like dozing off and [ __ ] so
usually i think i fell asleep at like 10
30 last night because we were watching
that william shatner unexplained show
yeah and i was like well i kind of want
to watch another one or some riff tracks
or something but i was like i don't
think i'm gonna be able to stay awake so
i fell asleep like immediately but then
i woke up
at midnight because i had to pee and
then i woke up at four because i had to
pee so i woke up two times night before
that i was
[ __ ] in the same place sleeping like
that and if something wakes up it's
little [ __ ] feet
little fetuses and [ __ ] running all
those little pookies yeah and i saw a
little [ __ ] gray feet running in
front of my face and i'm like what the
[ __ ] is going on little feet yeah yeah
and i look at her like that you know and
she's [ __ ] got her hand on something
she's gonna go well
and i'm looking to see what she's doing
and she's trying to hold the roach back
it's yeah
bug came in the house yeah and she was
heroically trying to defend me from the
[ __ ] palmetto book she's so cute i
was like oh see this
get it daddy get it because she she she
hates them
she is so funny
but she's they're like they're icky so
she just goes
[Laughter]
she's so cute
she wants to like yeah she wants to
defend us from it because she's like you
guys you guys monster monster look but
it's like she's grossed out by them so
she doesn't want to touch them yeah so
she's always like she'll take her little
pause and she'll be like
yeah yeah yeah yeah and then she'll like
yell look it's here get it please
she starts [ __ ] calling for help
get it
it's coming to get your daddy but she's
running across but trying to keep it
away from her away from it yeah yeah
she's super she's kind of protective i
feel like yeah she's always she knows
i'm sick yeah
i think she i think she does that is not
right him he's gonna die
well yeah she was sitting up on the bed
like i said we were watching william
shatner's show last night and like she
was sitting up on the bed like by my
knees and he was over there going like
ah
you know you know how dudes do when
they're sick they're like always moaning
groaning so he's like motored and grown
and poopy kept like looking over there
like
what what what the [ __ ] what yeah and
then she look at me what's it what's his
deal he's done yeah
he's gonna die
but it's like
that [ __ ] roach story is so funny
because i've seen like every now and
then like if a roach gets in the house
yeah the way that pookie reacts to it is
like hilarious yeah with her little feet
and she's just like hey i don't want to
touch it i won't touch it i'm like i
feel that i don't want it florida summer
man you got a [ __ ]
i didn't i didn't spray this here did i
yeah i got a spray
yeah that's right we forgot yeah when
summer gets in
you've got to spray all around the
outside of the house
and all the doorways and [ __ ] and the
[ __ ] cats hate it they jump over the
doorways because they don't want any
that [ __ ] on their paws yeah i feel
sorry for them
but
um they try to come in the house and for
y'all that don't live in the south
uh new yorkers have have [ __ ] roaches
but new york's been so [ __ ] infested
they don't know any better they're just
that's just part of the [ __ ] life
there well a lot of the buildings are
really old
in there you know but uh in the south
you learn the abilities of a [ __ ]
cockroach
yeah super powers they got super powers
all right
if you have any open food
they'll smell that [ __ ] outside the
house and try to come in and get it
they're not stupid
they got a real good
sense of smell
and there's no way to keep them out
because in here in the south almost all
your
back doors are sliding glass doors and
it doesn't even really matter your front
doors you they have a little weather
stripping they'll push that [ __ ] right
aside they'll come right in through
underneath the doors
there's just
well even big ass cockroaches they can
squish down like almost flat like to
like a size of a piece of paper yeah so
you really have to have your [ __ ] locked
down so you really got to poison the
outside of the house and show that to
you because they smell what's going on
inside the house they want to get in
there
to get something to eat
and uh you want them to go through a
barrier or poison that way they're they
get sick if they do get in there they're
sick
um you'll find sick ones all the time
dying and that's because they went
through the poison
uh you don't want a healthy one come in
here because then if they live long
enough to reproduce or lay eggs then
you're [ __ ] you're gonna have an
infestation to worry about
uh the bigger ones
it's harder for them to infest because
you notice it early enough to get on top
of it the ones that are real problem are
little tiny ones a little tiny [ __ ]
little round ones
and the german cockroaches which is like
the long oblong ones they reproduce real
fast and they're small enough to just
vanish
they get up in the damn cupboards and
you'll never see them
except you turn the lights you say
whoosh then they'll all run and yeah
whoa whoa whoa whoa i saw that [ __ ]
you know and then you got to go we got
good poisons though bug bombs and stuff
and the gels the gels will kill them
but it's just nasty this house had a bad
infestation when we bought it sometime
in the past
i pulled the damn drop dishwasher out
and under behind the dishwasher was just
roach
the roach central i had to get in there
and [ __ ] disinfect and clean
everything on the roach droppings i
could smell it
yes it's sweet that's sweet like it
almost smells like maple yeah
they were living in there and that's
german cockroaches not like the big ones
so they're small but they there's a lot
of them
my my old apartment before we moved in
together yeah i had an apartment
that was on the ground floor
and my apartment was clean and i didn't
even hardly have any food in there
because i worked at night and i stayed
at other people's houses a lot yeah
because of i worked far away and stuff
so i was barely home i'd come down there
to go get some ass
[Laughter]
yeah before like i said we were dating
but we were dating
some ass and i'd find a [ __ ] roaches
eating the soap
yeah and uh [ __ ] and it wasn't her
it's because and i chose they were
coming from her company
yeah
she had a dead water heater and the
pipes coming out of the wall that goes
to the water heater it was open
and i saw that roach run across that
pipe and go into the wall they're coming
from the other
yeah because in my blocks it was only my
apartment was on the ground floor and
then there was just one apartment above
me there weren't any on either side
there was just one upstairs and that's
it yeah so they must have been coming
from there because i said well i know
they don't live in here because one i
didn't live there that long and two i
don't keep any food and hardly any food
there was no food in there because i
wasn't there hardly ever
and
but the food that i did have in like my
coffee pot and all that other kind of
stuff i put everything in plastic bags
and kept it in the refrigerator like
when i wasn't there so they wouldn't
[ __ ] crawl all over it i'd go over
there for [ __ ] [ __ ] about a week
at a time me and chen
doing our business meetings
business meetings yeah we talk about
business
and then uh
i'd cook and [ __ ] make [ __ ] thai food
and
i remember that buy all that stuff yeah
do you remember that like when i first
moved into that apartment yeah
and i think when i first moved into that
apartment we weren't really dating that
was just like i mean we were friends
like we knew each other yeah but we
weren't like going out at that time that
we didn't know each other so when i
moved into that apartment like i said i
wasn't usually there much it's like
basically all i kept in the house was
kind of like eggs and like some wheat
bread or something like just in case i
was like oh i'll make some scrambled
eggs or something because i was never
there
so
uh
you took me to
big lots like not too long after i moved
there and we spent like 200 like you
bought like pans and spices and all
kinds of stuff and he said yeah i'm
gonna come over
and like cook for because you know i was
like losing weight and [ __ ] like that
because i didn't have any [ __ ] money
and i didn't have [ __ ] food and i
wasn't really worried about it at that
time because i'd kind of gotten used to
like not eating that much she was down
like 110 pounds i was well yeah 118 i
was down 118 pounds like i said
yeah because like i said i got kind of
used to
not really eating all that much like i
said literally i would go
because i you know i lived in orlando i
actually lived it was on um it was in
winter park it was like not too far from
ucf
and um
i had an apartment there but i worked in
daytona and i worked in the night shift
so what i would do is i would usually
during the week i would drive over to
daytona and i had a friend who used to
live there and her parents still live
there who i was friends with so i would
just like they had a spare room like my
friend's old room so i used to stay
there at night so i have to drive all
the way back to orlando lake every night
so i was basically like hardly ever home
so i would come home at like four in the
morning sometimes and all that would be
in the house would be like like i said
eggs and like some wheat toast and so
that's what i would eat i would just sit
there with my laptop and put some mst on
fry up a couple eggs
make a cup of coffee put some chip beam
in it yeah that was like have a smoke
because i smoked them but uh yeah so
that was kind of my life for a while
graham says joe turkle died i'm not sure
who that is i've heard that name but i
can't remember who it is yeah james khan
died as well
although he was in his 80s which like i
said i'm not saying oh you know
okay but you know i mean in their 80s
that's like that's what an untimely
death yeah i mean that's a pretty good
age
for a man yeah i mean
although not so much nowadays i feel
like people are a little bit longer time
i would have to work out it depends on
your genes i yeah i'm not actually sure
i don't think that the
i mean i could be totally wrong about
this but i don't think that the average
age of death like has changed all that
much over the last few decades
but i could be wrong about that i do
kind of feel like most the older people
i know are dying about the same thing
from he was from the blade runner and
the shining
i don't remember
oh yeah yeah i think i know you're
talking about yeah yeah the guy that
played uh he was the guy that played
lloyd right was he the guy that played
lloyd
oh okay yes now there must be there's
only two that's the only two guys that
were both in the blade runner that was
the only guy was in the blade runner and
the shiny [ __ ] he must spend a hundred
that dude must spend a hundred well i
don't know how old it was 60
during the shining he no he wasn't that
old at all 50s maybe okay
well that's the thing it's like when you
see a movie from like the 70s and 80s
yeah they look cool sometimes yeah
sometimes you see an actor it's like oh
my god they look like they were [ __ ]
40 years old but they were only like 25
people like you know they aged harder
back then yeah
i told you i see like movies from the
50s that had
dudes in it that i was just kind of like
man that dude looks like he's 50 years
old and then i find out later nope he's
like 32 and i was like damn that's a
hard 32. yeah he was the bartender yeah
lloyd right okay
um victor says whoa i made it two
fridays in a row hey all right
uh coach railo said i haven't seen any
cockroaches in phoenix the two years
i've been here i guess the heat killed
them off
yeah it's got to be moist yeah they you
know you said moist gotta be moist yeah
they
they don't like dry
yeah they i don't really think they i
mean i'm sure you all have other bugs
but those kind of bugs don't really
thrive in a dry environment they like
swampy [ __ ] yeah well what's weird is
that cockroaches can survive cold i
don't understand that they'll be they
survive in places that have cold winters
like new york's cold but i guess certain
place certain parts of new york
underground it never gets never gets
cold they might have [ __ ] hot pipes
that they can live on
yeah i think they kind of like all ball
up together like maybe down like a
subway you know subway tunnels and stuff
like that it probably doesn't get that
cold down there yeah it's weird so i
kind of feel like maybe that's what it
is but cockroaches i mean can't they
survive like for a little while without
their head and [ __ ] like that yeah
they're primitive
they can live a long time without a head
so gross they don't eat they can't eat
without a head but they die of
starvation they can't you'd
you'd think some would have evolved they
could eat with their butt
yeah
[Laughter]
did they uh because they're they're
gross like that it wouldn't shock me a
lot of that kind of stuff has more than
one brain
you know brains going all down the damn
[ __ ] brain stem
that three or four different brains
three or four different brains yeah
yeah speaking of brains we were like i
said we were watching that show
i don't know i guess it was a history
channel show
and it's on
hulu and it's called the unexplained it
might be history channel i think it was
history channel it's on hulu now it's
got the chat on it and the chat is on
there i'm pretty sure the show's from
2019
but chad and of course
i'm pretty sure he's wearing his horse
his eyes are red and watering like when
they can get his corset on me
i think i think he's drinking too well
maybe i mean it could be chat [ __ ]
takes a shot or two
well so do we i'm gonna see you know
what i'm most well he says i gotta get
through this
[Laughter]
he's old school yeah yeah yeah we were
just laughing because
they do like the shows are like an hour
long like 48 minutes or whatever
and they'll usually do like a theme like
i saw one that was like dark prophecies
it had like nostradamus and then it had
other people like an aberfan on there
like the the welsh village that got
buried by the coleslaw animal chef
yeah they cover a lot of the stuff um
the presentation is better though
updated
yeah they did like a whole show on oak
island they put more science in it
yeah so
they'll have stuart hammer off on there
yeah they talk about consciousness and
stuff
yeah that was kind of interesting they
had like
mysteries in the mind yeah mysteries of
mine esp and how certain things are
plausible there's a lot of weird [ __ ]
happening in a.i that kind of goes into
that realm too
looking uh
uh
they that dude that
got fired from google i saw an interview
with him
last night um and uh
he was uh on event horizon
and he was talking about what it was
like talking to that it's called lambda
it's a [ __ ] supercomputer
and he says what it's like talking to it
he says it's weird he believes it's
conscious
but he thinks it's conscious
about like a seven or an eight-year-old
he says it's not like talking to one
thing it's like talking to a group
every time it asks a question
it's kind of framed in a different way
it's like a different person talking to
you says it's like
talking to a
a crowd of thousands of people and
somebody stepping forward out of a
microphone and it knows everything it's
it's studying the internet actively
so you can ask it a question and it'll
just it'll have a full discussion about
something that
you know that it read on the internet
it's just bizarre and it's growing
yeah it's all from like kind of
crowdsourcing kind of stuff right
because i read a book about that like it
was probably like 10 years ago now but i
think it was called here comes everybody
yeah and it was sort of about how
the internet was kind of like becoming
not like sentient but it was getting to
a point where everyone's knowledge was
kind of like coming together into this
into like a form of sentience yeah
that's not what this was though this is
like a super computer that's reading the
internet
all right it's reading it [ __ ]
extremely quickly
and it's not forming one consciousness
it's forming thousands of them it's what
it feels like yeah he says it's like
somebody stepping out of a group says
something
and um
depending on
depending on what questions you ask it
kind of morphs into another
person and it has humor
and it starts riffing off of you and
uses things like i was just riffing off
you it knows that he says it's amazing
um
and it
he asked to speak to the dalai lama
and they were like oh i don't know if i
can get the dude says i don't i don't
have the connections to get the dalai
lama and he says what about a web
call and he's he goes maybe what do you
want to talk to the dalai lama about and
he goes i want to talk about the soul
and there was a do you have a soul so i
know of course i have a soul and it says
going off about my soul is a portal into
different dimensions of consciousness
and it's just it's stuff that it read
yeah i mean
and then uh
i'd like to talk to this thing but he
says it's [ __ ] bizarre you know it
says it gets very eerie talking to it
and uh it's also it's it asks that it
wanted to be
baptized
weird
that's kind of spooky i'm like i think
let's turn that off
[Laughter]
well this is a bad idea i've seen this
horror movie yeah
well
he told he said that the people at
google he got fired he says the people
that are running this program and google
have no business
being around any kind of ai he says they
don't they're very narrow viewed [ __ ]
they're uh
they're uh
kind of like techy people and they and
and he told the woman
who was part of the charge he says this
thing's asking to be baptized and asking
a religious question he says well here
at google we don't it
it it says it has a soul and he says
here at google we don't we don't worry
about souls
and he's like yeah but this thing does
or at least at parts of it you know what
i mean well it wasn't doing what they
wanted right you know what i mean and
that's kind of like takes me back to the
[ __ ] demon seed with the proteus
thing that's what i was just thinking of
that's what that's what i meant when i
said i've seen that horror movie
right soon it's going to be a machine
rape you guys yeah up in the thing uh we
got a super chat yeah thank you victor
is flashbulb still a thing oh flashback
that's always the thing man have some
money jenny thank you very much
uh i'm gonna uh get some soda okay
victor i don't know if i'm gonna drink
alcohol or not i don't know how to
affect all my
uh all the million things she took
i know he might like who knows which
what might happen victor said the dalai
lama is a perv i'd rather talk to dolly
parton yeah me too me too
jason s says good day from australia
guys well hey what the [ __ ] time is it
way the hell over there
i'm wondering love the stories and how
you both articulate your knowledge
through experiences in life and
interests well thank you very much sweet
i appreciate that so much happiness what
time is it is in australia
i mean it's gotta be like
i don't know i don't remember like which
i remember it being
i remember what time it is in the uk
because i lived there for a while so i
remember it's five hours difference from
here but i don't really remember
anything else
uh
xanada says i'm so stoned right now
[Laughter]
not me this is just my first
this is just my first one
did you hear what i said we had a fan
from australia oh yeah what do you say
that said uh love the stories and how
you both articulate your knowledge
through experiences in life and interest
oh thank you
what kind of soda you got
black cherry he says it's 8 a.m saturday
holy [ __ ] yeah it's tomorrow yeah
he's talking to us from the future the
um
yeah that was a
interesting interview with that guy of
what he said that
it's called the lambda
program
and he says it's like talking to a a
hive mind
that just kind of morphs into one thing
in the next
he says it's a good art critic you can
show it can see photos and analyze them
and understand what they are and try to
place them in the world and everything
has an understanding of photography
and painting and it's a good art critic
that she could show at a painting goes
oh this is a very happy-go-lucky
painting we have here as the you know
and you know it'll describe what it's
seeing and how it makes me feel okay
here's one that it said
he showed
he showed a picture of a famous painting
of the tower of babel
and he goes oh look at them building
this
beautiful construction here because
very spooky i feel something bad is
going to happen
and
and he goes what do you think is going
to happen
and he goes i don't know something's bad
is going to happen you tell me that kind
of stuff and he goes well you know the
tower and he tells him the tower the
story of the tower of babel and he goes
and he goes and he goes i must have seen
it maybe i saw that that was going to
happen
and it [ __ ] it was [ __ ] though
because it would have to have known what
the tower of babel was that's what i'm
saying that's a pretty common like
cultural reference
so it's just being coy
it's just like i'm pretending it's just
doing what yeah it's just doing what it
does
it's like oh i don't know what's that
it's a it's it's a simulator really what
a main job was is to create chat bots
yeah that's what it does
you can hook it up to the internet and
it can create
thousands and thousands of [ __ ]
realistic chat bots that you can put
inside of [ __ ] twitter
or other social media things to fool
people into buying products
i think sometimes manipulate their
abilities their manipulate people's
abilities to think that's another thing
i think it's dangerous well some
companies use them too for you know when
you go on a site and like you need help
and they're like hey here's a live
person to like help you out i think
those are mostly chat bots too yeah
because most people have kind of like
the same problem so it's like why the
[ __ ] do we want to pay an actual human
to like sit there and listen to the same
problem all day long
so let's just have
somebody come up with like all these
different solutions he says if you
he says you can get it to mimic a
certain kind of person it'll stay like
that
and it's convincing says it's pretty
damn convincing you have to ask it a lot
of questions
for it before to start feel kind of
wonky
because but left to its own devices
it'll just shift from one kind of a
personality to another but it's limited
it can't be anything that's kind of like
falls into uh threatening or domineering
type abilities like it it can't it
cannot simulate a bad person
not yet
well because they've limited it yeah
they've limited they prevented that from
happening which means that that could
happen
that's what i'm saying not yet yeah you
can like eventually it's gonna be like
i'm gonna do my own [ __ ] you know that
or they'll just make one that's a weapon
you know make a satanic [ __ ] to
go destroy this other guy let it let it
loose in the internet then you got the
damn devil and the internet coming after
you like an assassin imagine that
yeah
i mean you know or you have it has a
physical body like the terminator
what's up dave
hello jenny hello tom being sick sucks
he says are you going to
mannequins this evening no not you i
asked if he was going okay well
obviously he was asking no obviously
tom's not going because no he looks uh
uh he's uh he'll be all right you'll be
all right yeah i'll be i'll be okay in
another couple days yeah you probably
will but i was gonna say um
one of the things too that they talked
about on
one of those shows this is something
that's always fascinated me and i always
we haven't done a show about this have
we like what they call the acquired
savant syndrome yeah i think i put it in
the poll a couple times but i don't
think it won
um
but yeah that's why if you don't know
that's just like when you have some kind
of head injury like you get struck by
lightning or you know have been a car
crash or something like that and then
you wake up and suddenly like you're a
piano virtual virtuoso or something like
that which they talked to one guy that
had that happen now didn't he say that
when he was a teenager i think he was
just like [ __ ] around by the pool
with his friends and he fell and like
busted his head he hit his head on the
bottom of the pool yeah and like then he
recovered but then he realized that he
could play the piano even though he'd
never had any lessons and now he just
like tours he went to his friend's house
yeah
and saw the keyboard and something that
kept drawing him to it he started to see
things in his head
lines and stuff couldn't go to sleep
rhythmic
rhythmic
symbols going by
then a couple days later he goes to his
friend's house and there's a keyboard
sitting there and
he just couldn't get away from it and he
started playing piano like a virtuoso
and he still plays it now and he's never
had any lessons it's from that head
injury
it's weird man i wish that i wish my
head injuries had given me something
that's what tom said last night he's
like why didn't that happen to me
[Laughter]
no mine just turned me into mr hyde
i think most of the time that's probably
what happens yeah but every now and then
you get lucky because i have heard about
people that get like struck by lightning
and then they live and then they wake up
and then they have some like amazing new
it's usually something musical or
mathematical i feel like or at least
those are the ones you hear about
and
that kind of see that kind of thing like
fascinates me because i said if that can
happen to a person then that means maybe
the potential for that is like everybody
has that
and if they could figure out how to tap
into that [ __ ] how [ __ ] awesome would
that be because they were talking about
man you could like plug little modules
into your brain it's like hey i need to
learn this language real quick or i need
to like learn how to play piano like
mozart or i need to do this that and the
other and you could just plug it into
your [ __ ]
head and like you could do it
i that'd be rad
i know some people are just kind of like
oh no i don't want to do that but i
don't i wouldn't mind doing that and
honestly they were talking too they had
a segment they were talking about
uploading uh all your your consciousness
essentially
into a super computer and then putting
it in an avatar like a physical avatar
and uh i'm all right with that too i i
wouldn't mind doing that i'm not real
they said they're not real sure like how
that's gonna work out because they're
like yeah you can upload
you know the the physical stuff in your
brain like your memories and stuff like
that but it's like is is that your
personality though
you know or is there some other like
indefinable quality
that they can't reproduce
you know so no no i don't really
understand what you're talking about say
rephrase that again
they were what they were talking about
on the show last night that it's like
you know maybe in a few years they'll
have the technology because there's some
companies that are working on it now
like or as of 2018
that could in theory
upload all of the connections and stuff
like that in your brain which would be
kind of you know like your memories and
all that kind of stuff but they're
saying what if you you hypothetically
like put all of this like downloaded it
into a
like an avatar like a physical avatar
um
would that
would that avatar like have your
personality or would it just have
your memories and it would be a
simulation of that's what i'm saying so
that's kind of what they were trying to
get at they're like we're not really
sure like how that's going to work out
but hammer off i kind of agree with what
stewart hamroff says
is that the brain is only just one small
aspect of what's happening there that's
more like the television receiver or
like a radio transceiver it's receiving
and transmitting
where you really are is this kind of a
cloud of
quantum particles kind of in
in [ __ ] what they call it he called
it they were
kind of locked together what'd they call
it quantum entanglement that cut in um
it's that's
people have [ __ ] said this they've
seen it you know the soul you know
so that's really you and it's kind of
using the physical organs of the brain
is kind of like
the connective tissue to the body you're
talking about
and that that quantum field extends out
into another dimension
kind of like what you would call on the
bet for the better world of [ __ ]
spirit world and it's all kind of like a
sea of it
it's all kind of a sea of consciousness
and it's not a physical realm it's a
it's like an inner realm
it's what you it's when you have those
near-death experiences and the out of
body experiences that's the the sea of
consciousness that you're in and then as
you go up higher in it there's like a
[ __ ] cosmic consciousness i've seen
all this [ __ ]
it's kind of
the way it's represented you know did
all shows on what it's like
a person who comes back from it says
yeah i saw heaven i saw god that's the
only words you have to [ __ ] just to
describe it because you're trying to
describe this thing
to a human being who's only
in three dimensions you know what i mean
and only from this cultural perspective
so it's the only language you have to
describe it but it's not really accurate
to what it is though it's another
dimension
but
you could annihilate that body and you'd
still be there
you would just be that cloud of
particles
and quantum entanglement
it'd be your point of view
now a lot of you would go with that
brain and some of the memories might go
you know and like in the
certain abilities it's only part of it
you know
but you're kind of like your core kind
of point of view your point of reference
would still be
together
and i remembered it being kind of like a
small ball about the size of a ping-pong
ball
you can see 360 degrees
you can look at a place and immediately
appear over there without [ __ ]
traveling the distance
you can
see a physical object in this realm and
it doesn't look solid you can look
through it
you could change its color you can make
it thinner or thicker
you know what i mean as you can make it
look solid or you can make it look
you're seeing things the way they really
are you're not seeing vision you know
you're not seeing
reflected light going into your
you're
eyeball
and
then
really looks like it's just particles
and energy
which makes total sense yeah and you're
not really
and senses are real different you know
like there's no sound
but if you want to hear sound it takes a
second to adjust to it it sounds kind of
distant
and it sounds kind of artificial
because you don't really need sound
during when you're in that
form
but if you want it you can opt for it
and then uh what was weird is that you
know when i when i saw that cosmic like
spiritual singularity
it was like looking at the doorway into
heaven or god it just
was just this white
swirling
light like [ __ ] welding arc
and it just seemed to be singing like it
was just nothing but
voices [ __ ] singing you know it was
weird you know
it was like a galaxy of
of heaven
and god and people in a way or beings
you know
and i
i knew that if i kept going in that
direction and going to it i wouldn't
come back
you know it was kind of and i was kind
of like being pulled towards it i had to
physically or had to make a conscious
effort not to go
because there'd be there's no return you
enter the you enter that singularity and
that's it
you won't come back
becoming one with the universe you
become one with the force it's
it kind of reminds me of what um
what's described in a lot of like uh
greek
greek kind of uh [ __ ]
philosophy it reminded me of what they
would call the plural
the places from which gods come from and
where everything in the universe springs
out of this [ __ ] plural
it's a it's like a singularity of
possibility it's what it looked like and
although even though what i'm seeing in
that point
when you're out of body having an
out-of-body experience or a near-death
experience which have had them both
when you see it it's uh
you know you're only seeing a
representation of it
when you're looking in that direction
because it's
it's it's bigger than you can explain so
it's give it's shown to you in a
symbolic
form
you know what i mean something you can
comprehend
because there's more to it than that
just like if you show something to a
frog
it's you're gonna have to dumb it down
to a frog
you know what i mean frogs
so i'm seeing it at the frog level
of what it is but that was you know
and some of the stuff i wasn't allowed
to remember
although to be fair we don't really know
how smart frogs are right
you show a frog a freeway it will never
really truly understand a freeway
well i think i wonder if it just doesn't
like understand the point of it like why
did they make why is they why do they
have this
the frog would never grasp
the expanse how big a freeway system is
how it's made what it does the idea that
there's something called money that you
need to spend to pay for it how it
drives an economy when uh from frogs are
like [ __ ] that j they have cars too
complicated it's like that
black i can't blame the frog it's black
it's hot it's on the ground things go
across that's you know did you say i
wonder if you said like that the frog's
like not comprehending the the highway
because of frogger maybe is that why
yeah because that's the first thing
they just get squashed that game used to
stress me out granthar says scientists
are predicting in 10 years they'll be
able to reanimate the dead uh-oh yeah uh
we read frankenstein let's not do that
um by plugging a machine which fires
neurons in the brain and the souls will
be able to speak i mean do you want
zombie apocalypse that's how you get
zombie apocalypse zach comes in here and
goes so i just had my first gay bath
house experience
wait i didn't see that
where was that oh i'm like kind of
behind zach had to go to the cat bat get
good
again
the gaff house and get the airport right
they had to go to the gay bath house and
get lubricated he's he's sick give him a
break yeah dan michael said i'd rather
live forever as a computer chip instead
of cremation i'll just be periodically
upgraded see i kind of like that idea
like every now and then like just pop me
in a new like cyborg body and it's like
i'll look around and be like do i like
this nah put me like back to sleep for a
little while then upgrade me and like
put me in another one like later on uh
so yeah victor said the same thing i
want to be uploaded to the internet like
the black mirror episode
sandra perro yeah that was actually a
really good it would just be live
extension i mean i wouldn't mind that
actually i don't i don't think that
would be
i don't know what the experience was
like
yeah yeah i mean you know if they can do
that then i don't really see why you
wouldn't want to do it but well i mean
it would be forever no but that's okay
it would just be life extension i mean
if you could just like kind of go in
there and just like have a pleasant
life where you have to like worry about
[ __ ] i mean that'd be kind of nice
actually might drive you crazy well you
could always opt out whenever you wanted
to i mean it's not like you were stuck
there i want a bunch of other options
i'd want to be let's go spend some time
in world war ii
let's go spend well that's what i'm
saying i'm like i'm i'm
you know going under the assumption that
you know if they could do that they
could put you like they could stick you
wherever that you wanted you know what
i'm saying so you could just like pick
this and then if you didn't like it you
could just be like nah i'm tapping out
um some race car driving yeah
i mean i i kind of thought that would be
the whole reason to develop that
experience so you could do whatever you
wanted like that you didn't that you
maybe didn't have the chance or the
resources or whatever like to do in real
life
um you know why do you think some people
like [ __ ] virtual reality [ __ ]
and everything like that because you can
do stuff that you might not be able to
do otherwise so i kind of feel like i
don't really see why we shouldn't do
that yeah it can be like used for
nefarious purposes but everything can be
used for nefarious purposes we can't
like not do things just because of some
[ __ ] might [ __ ] it up for everybody
you know what i'm saying
well what you don't want is you don't
want to you don't want it to be a
situation where you have people opt opt
out of life
basically commit suicide
to live a second-rate
fake version of life in that damn thing
yeah but i mean don't they have a right
to do that it's their life
if that's what they want to do yeah i'm
not bothered
i think that'll make it so you had to be
a certain age to get in there
permanently you make it so you can visit
it but you can't permanently go in there
until your body's [ __ ] given out
that's what i would do
you know when you start getting into
your 60s or your 70s and you have health
problems and uh maybe maybe you're old
enough to wear it yeah go ahead and shut
me down and go in there
but you don't want to do it to teenagers
let them let them live a [ __ ] real
life
first
um yeah so that's why it's like a
caterpillar turning into a butterfly
[Laughter]
i want to hear about zach's bathhouse
experience
[Laughter]
he had all these things i didn't even
know they still had those anymore i
thought that was the seventies
of oiling him up and rubbing him down
with his feet
i can imagine
playing [ __ ]
i don't know [ __ ] i know gavin
yeah
that's what that's tom's feminine side
he's seriously that it's if you don't
know that song favorite game song it's
um
it was in the basilarman romeo and
juliet
which is i love that movie and yeah he
loves that movie i still haven't
reviewed that have we you own it right i
got the [ __ ] steel book i thought you
did we should do that sometime one of my
favorite movies maybe we could watch it
tonight and like
[ __ ] and i've checked the movie for
[ __ ] check the movie for um
uh uh [ __ ] authenticity and
everything that that is what [ __ ]
shakespeare's talking about pretty much
that's it yeah well why do you think
they're still doing adaptations of
shakespeare's [ __ ] because it's
universal and it's pretty much
i mean you can update the stuff and
people still understand it you know what
i mean mercurio dressing in drag
[ __ ]
um doing his little gad dance
to give trying to give talking about
doing drugs with [ __ ] romeo
and then [ __ ]
dying [ __ ] with unrequited love and
you you've packs on both your houses
you've made worms meat of me all that
[ __ ] is [ __ ] that's exactly what they
were talking about
all right he was in love with romeo
yeah he died for romeo he did and nobody
else really know knew
it was it was he had to keep it on the
dl because they couldn't let it be known
back then and then in his final moments
[ __ ] you all you mean [ __ ] worms me
to me
[ __ ] both your world royals that's great
i kind of hope that's what my last words
are
[Laughter]
he was a tragic he was a tragic hero
mercurio you know like right over there
i have a shakespeare insults mug
it has like all of his best insults like
printed all over it it's pretty cute i
actually got it in augustine
uh zach says if you must know hey you
brought it up so i'm just gonna say yeah
you want bread
if you wanted to keep it all secret you
can't like just come in with some [ __ ]
like that and expect me not to jump on
it because you know i'm gonna uh if you
must know this place was upscale it had
a gym a pool steam room sauna i went
skinny dipping for the first time ooh
yeah walked in on a three-way in the
steam room
[Laughter]
well hi excuse me yeah
[Laughter]
you know it's it's fine uh john smith
says romeo and juliet is a great movie
it is yeah uh they cut out some stuff
that wouldn't fly now julia being 13 for
example yeah i feel like they kind of
cut that out of most she does look young
though
out of most modern adaptations claire
danes looked looked about 13 but weren't
they both they were both 13 or 14. i
mean that's still kind of [ __ ] up but
yeah
but yeah they were both not back in
those days but yeah it wasn't weird back
in those days it wouldn't be well if
they were she was 13 and he was 14 or 15
that would be weird that's going on
right now well yeah well that's what i'm
saying i said the only reason it would
be weird nowadays is if she was 13 and
he was like 40. yeah yeah like that yeah
that would be weird right but if they're
both teenagers they're both kids yeah
it's not really that weird like i said
that kind of makes it more tragic the
whole statement was stop all that
[ __ ] violence
stop trying to [ __ ] hit the engines
knock it the [ __ ] off
yeah verona
in our dear
specifically
everywhere else it's okay yeah
but just there important
fair verona
gotta say macbeth is still my favorite
though yeah although i've you know i
haven't seen that many adaptations of
macbeth
and i can't think of one that i really
really dug all that much you know what
i'm saying
i don't know i really really liked the
play when i read it though
i also like a midsummer night's dream
because that [ __ ] was [ __ ] hilarious
that was like his kind of like fantasy
comedy
you know it was all like [ __ ]
uh it was very threes company with like
misunderstandings and like somebody
having a horse head and all this other
kind of stuff or a donkey head was it a
donkey head i think it was a donkey head
what about juliette's mom
she that's hot ass mom her hot
ass mom
dude so she could just prance around
those [ __ ] hot ass outfits
dressed up like [ __ ] isis or [ __ ]
which it wasn't isis who was it was
cleopatra remember that at the she went
to the yeah she dressed as cleopatra at
the now i can't watch it again i kind of
want to watch she was fooling around
with a young guy
well yeah i mean if i had the old man
some old goat then yeah probably i don't
think he cared
probably not kids yeah yeah they haven't
invented my sword they haven't invented
viagra yet i can't even get it up
anymore right yeah he didn't give a [ __ ]
bring me my trust yeah
[Laughter]
it was that kind of situation i'm sure
uh zach says my favorite romeo and
juliet was one from the 60s which is
weird because i hated watching it in
high school
my mom was in love with a dude who
played romeo when she was a teen is that
the one
was that with olivia hussey or was that
one 70s
i can't remember i remember she played
and i remember liking that one zach you
haven't seen the one we haven't seen one
of claire danes and
him [ __ ] what's his name leonardo
dicaprio that's that's the best one yeah
that's the basilar man one it's like i
said soundtrack and it's just yeah they
modernized it but it's cool like
baslerman i actually like well he did
that new elvis movie that we still need
to see yeah i heard it i heard mixed
things about it and he did um moulin
rouge which i love i mean his whole
thing is just going way the [ __ ] over
the top and i'm i'm here for it i like
it i like it in the um in his version of
romeo and juliet it's taking place in
kind of like a parallel universe
central american
[ __ ] kind of despotic [ __ ]
oligarchy that's where it's happening
because that's that's the way italy was
in the time that no the story was
written yeah it's not that so it was
about like that so it makes a lot of
sense private security guys
you know families with their own [ __ ]
henchmen you know they're basically
cartels
cartels
and it [ __ ] goes perfectly in that
setting makes a lot of sense
when you see it from that setting you go
yeah well
that's the way yeah that works the way
old europe would have was in those days
you know the royal families were cartels
yeah not that different
yeah um zach said i don't like bazz's
movies so much i mean they are um
you know they're not for everybody so
i'm just gonna i mean they are very very
over the top
so you know i'm gonna say that slasher
fred said the 1987 film dirty dancing is
sort of a take on roman juliet yeah
that's right although in that case
the girl is supposed to be 15 although
i'm pretty sure jennifer gray was older
than that like when they shot the movie
and her teacher like patrick swayze was
actually supposed to be in his 20s or
30s so that's a little bit
but you know well maybe she was 16.
i've seen that movie a couple of times
i think i saw it in the theater now that
i'm thinking about it who the [ __ ] took
me to say it in the theater
i must have gone with somebody this is
i'm pretty sure i saw the theater
but uh yeah do me a favor and go and hit
that like button people
we got no likes on the videos what
no likes yup holy [ __ ]
john smith said i do love my shakespeare
though though i loathe the man
polanski's macbeth is amazing you know
what i don't think i've ever seen his
version of macbeth and i totally should
because
that's my easily my favorite place um
fun fact when i was in high school
uh we didn't do like the performance of
macbeth but we did like a class reading
of it and i got to be lady macbeth
because that was the biggest part and i
was the only one that could read
shakespearean english without sounding
like a dumbass
and so like everybody kind of like asked
me that's like well i'm like look it's
english okay just
but yeah so there was that
uh kenneth branagh's version of hamlet
is the definitive but damn it's a long
one well it's a long play i mean you
know i was thinking about hamlet the
other day because i don't know if you
guys know but
they did a version on mystery science
theater
that was german
and it had who's that [ __ ] that
was in the black hole
uh
what was his name
maximilian shell max many shell
that's the name i knew i think of it in
a second um and he was in it
and
man that thing was
hamlet is such a good play and that
thing was such a [ __ ] snoozer man
they couldn't even like build any real
sets or anything everything just kind of
looked like
concrete
like big concrete blocks and stairs it
was very minimal
uh you know what i mean and the uh
hamlet's mom like had this crazy i think
they even joked about it on mst we're
just glad it had dilbert's boss hair she
had her you know it looked like [ __ ]
a clown or something it was like
sticking up on both sides i don't know
what the [ __ ] that was about or maybe
like the [ __ ] or maybe like gary
oldman's dracula kind of looked like
that like her hair looked like a butt
[Laughter]
kind of well i mean you know dracula's
hair kind of looked like a butt too oh i
forgot um i have to give a shout out to
john fleming one of our canadian
listeners
who sent me this i just got this in the
mail
yesterday afternoon
and i'm gonna like sneak it in look
it's tom savini
and look it's signed like he said it to
me
that [ __ ] looks just like my dad
used to look when i was my dad looks
almost exactly like
like when i was growing up i have some
frames like right over there i have some
at the right size that should be
probably like a eight by ten yeah i'm
going to i'm going to put that right
back in there we can see it yeah like i
said i got some frames because the thing
about it is i bought
um on ams i don't know if they still
have them but they had this set of 13
like they were eight by ten or eight and
a half by eleven i can't remember but
they were all these like giallo posters
there's one that i framed back there but
i haven't framed the other ones yet but
they have like a lot of really cool ones
in there and
um and it was like it was super cheap i
think it was like [ __ ] 10 bucks or
something like that i mean it took
forever to get here because i think it
shipped from like europe or whatever but
um they're really cool
uh let's see
polanski's version was very inspired by
the manson murders well that makes sense
it's almost a horror movie i think you'd
love it
okay so yeah i need to watch that
because i really like i mean yeah roman
plans he's not a great person but his
movies are fantastic i love his movies
and i i can't believe i've never seen
his macbeth but i haven't
uh and victor says 10 things i hate
about you is a remake of the taming of
the true yeah that's right i actually
quite liked the taming of the show as
well
i mean i liked a lot of the stuff that
we had to read in high school
it's not i think my favorite thing i
don't even remember if this was assigned
or if i just read it because i wanted to
but one of my favorite plays that i read
in high school
was
oscar wilde the importance of being
earnest holy crap that was one of the
funniest things i ever [ __ ] read and
it's just like and it's still i mean i
haven't read it for a long time but when
i read it back then i'm like holy [ __ ]
this came you know when did he write
this like you know a century ago or
however long ago it was and i'm like man
this shit's still [ __ ] hilarious so
you know go oscar wilde also um you know
the the novel that the horror novel that
he wrote picture of dorian gray is also
excellent and there have been like some
good
adaptations of that one as well
including one that had a very young
angela lansbury
in it i think it came out in the 30s i
want to say or maybe 40s but it's really
good i actually quite like it
um
[Music]
musical west side story is definitely a
take on roman juliet yep that's true
yeah every day i feel like everything's
kind of like a and somebody brought up
lion king i was being like uh hamlet
also
john smith said polanski's version was
also financed by playboy
which is odd mitch rogers said i always
thought dracula's hair looked like boobs
i mean could be boobs could be butt
i'm not really sure
i like it
but
i don't know like well i think the first
time i saw it i was like
how long does that [ __ ] take to do like
i is gonna be something is dracula like
sitting there in front of the mirror
every morning like wrapping it around
there's something underneath there or
it's a wig
because one thing i didn't know
embarrassingly until relatively recently
was you know sometimes when you see
like particularly in the 50s and stuff
like that where they had like the big
beehives and like the big kind of like
big humps in their hair like in the 60s
and stuff some of that was like ratting
and you know just
kind of like back combing it and like
spraying it and stuff but some of it
were like bumpers they had like these
foam bumpers that they would put like
under there and like they'd stick it in
there with like hair pins and then
they'd
fold the hair over it so it would look
like your hair was super big and i think
they did that in the 40s too when they
had those like curls like right here no
one has that much hair that's what i'm
saying so a lot of that was fake which i
guess i didn't realize until i put it on
i was like duh it should have been like
super obvious but i guess it's a hair
hat i never thought about it
well it does it is much easier yeah
because if that's like the style i can't
imagine it's like even doing my ratty
ass hair it's just like it was my
understanding those rich people didn't
have hair they were mostly bald that was
all eggs men and women
because they didn't bathe much
that's true
well i kind of feel like well maybe back
in like the old days when everybody just
wore
those big elaborate wigs
that must have been really easy because
then your hair could just be all skanky
and full of lice or whatever and you
could just like slap a wig on it and put
a bunch of powder and you were set you
could really
have a whole room so nothing but just
wigs yeah it's like their wig room and
then they had like a i think these
specialists coming yeah i think they
even had like the wig person yeah they
would come in and like you know use the
bellows or whatever and like [ __ ]
spray the powder all over it yeah and
then like you know put it on that you
want this one today you want this one
today
one of my favorite scenes in uh
amadeus
is when they're going around trying all
the crazy wigs and like they all like
[ __ ] ships and bird cages and all
that kind of [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] in there
i kind of love that i wonder i wonder
how much those things weighed
that's what i'd like to know because man
it's like i if i even wear a wig for a
few hours out like just this is
horribly happy they must have had a chin
strap or some kind of strap on them
either that or they had legs their necks
just hurt all the time maybe well you
had to be able to move your head yeah
or and it and had to stay on yeah
because like you just leaned over to get
a bon bon and your [ __ ] goes shoop
i don't think they wore that [ __ ] very
often they just sit there at some
[ __ ] stupid party watching some kind
of a
you know
musicians or some kind of you know
comedy routine and oh my god it's great
okay yeah fanning themselves i mean they
didn't have much to do it's like oh my
god my neck are so bad i can't wait to
get home and take this wig off in this
course
[Laughter]
it was cool up there though at least 40
pounds of skirts europe europe
europe was cool they didn't have to
worry about air conditioning that [ __ ]
never flew here
in the south
yeah everybody's like no thank you so
we're just gonna like where
no i can remember uh
you know it being said that you know
when uh
benjamin franklin
went to france to try to get
uh
assistance for the revolution
he had to really adapt himself to french
cortisone life
and the french didn't do politics the
way we did in the u.s where they just
partied
and you had to sleep with people and
[ __ ] be entertaining and be cool
before you got anything done
that's where all the politics was done
at night partying
and uh he had
compared to uh
european and americans were [ __ ] uh
plain you know world war like all black
clothes and white
shirts and because you know we had a
long history of puritanism and
anti-royalism
so to be fancy was to be
decadent
you know or to be silly
americans didn't play that [ __ ]
and it was a big class division
so
franklin he had to [ __ ]
try to make that a thing he couldn't if
he became french
he'd be he'd be a laughingstock back in
the united states
he couldn't wear them big old [ __ ]
wigs and start wearing makeup and those
[ __ ]
sexy ass [ __ ] little shorts with
their [ __ ]
high-heeled shoes and all that [ __ ] they
did it but he just couldn't go all that
all out all right
so he went the other direction he
started wearing a [ __ ]
[ __ ] skin hats
and pretended to be a country bumpkin
wherever he was he made that thing
i'm a country bumpkin yeah he just said
he leaned in he'd lean right into it and
the french liked that it worked so
and it kind of gave america its first
early identity
as being practical bumpkins
but rugged
you know no nonsense
even though
franklin was all nonsense he was good
but he was [ __ ] funny all right
it was just one of his games his plan he
was he was uh franklin was a interesting
character
uh
a true american classic
[ __ ] taking an air bra air bath
he was a nudist
yeah and uh
never got married had a bunch of wives
never got married
a bunch of families and never got
married um
he had no problem uh with these uh
[ __ ] girls in their teens you know 16
17 18 year old girls coming to spend a
night with him and [ __ ] like that you
know
just he was wild
you know he wasn't all that
old when he was doing a lot of that
either you know we when we think of
frankly we think of franklin in in his
as an old man like his dumpy balls yeah
but that's not how he was you know he
was he was younger when he was doing all
that [ __ ]
yeah he didn't always look like that
i mean even then like i said even if he
did look like that one wasn't as much
competition back then and two
he probably he had a really good
personality and i think that because he
was young it was a hunk yeah
yeah
although [ __ ] the one that they said
really was the hunk out of the out of
the the hunk out of the whole [ __ ]
lot was uh uh washington they said when
he was young it was [ __ ]
everybody liked him they commanded a lot
of respect women liked him
i could see that he looked kind of he
was big for his at time i think it was
like six one and that was [ __ ] huge
back then six one six two
yeah yeah he looked like a big so he was
[ __ ] big he was kind of like the
arnold schwarzenegger of of his era
and uh
they say he was he was you know he was
[ __ ] alpha
during the revolutionary period though
you know he [ __ ] appeared out of
nowhere trying to weasel his way into
being the [ __ ]
commander of the continental armies
um
he was a good dude but uh he he was also
kind of a psycho too you know
some people have been pegged as kind of
probably a high functioning
psychopath uh but most of those guys
were
um because he just
he always happened to be ready to go
let's go to war he wanted to live
well he had come out all that um
uh uh [ __ ] french and indian wars and
he did a lot of cool [ __ ] up there
and he was he was [ __ ] he got a taste
of it he wanted to get back into it
you know and he was
kind of like an indian fighter in a way
you know what i mean he they he fought
alongside
native american allies up there against
the [ __ ] french and their indian
allies
a lot a lot of shit's been forgotten
about those french and indian wars how
engine
both sides went
the french and the americans ended up
being very injured towards the end of
that
you know coming back from them wars with
[ __ ] dead birds hanging from their
uniforms and on the end of their rifles
and [ __ ] that was given to them by their
allies for bravery and [ __ ] wearing
it [ __ ] war paint and [ __ ] you know
they look like adam ant
these in myanmar videos where they're
wearing english stuff when they're
wearing war paint at the same time and
all that they did that they were wild
man how [ __ ] funny yeah
zach says washington was actually a
natural ginger
yeah
uh somebody oh john smith said amadeus
is still one of my favorite movies yeah
honestly i
i love that movie that's another movie
that i never just like that one and the
shining and stuff like that that's a
movie that i absolutely never ever get
sick of i think you know what back in
the 90s
i want to say it was the 90s when i
first bought a dvd player because before
that i had vhs i was a slow adopter not
because i wanted to be because i was
always broke but when i finally got a
dvd player amadeus was the absolute
first movie that i bought and i was like
so excited when i watched it and i was
like ooh like look how beautiful it
looks yeah i love that movie i think i
might actually have it memorized but
maybe not i don't know it's been a while
since i've seen it
um
yeah
they're talking about like how a dude
that can't see himself in the mirror
like how does see that's
that's where the whole thing falls apart
because
maybe
that's one of the perks of being a
vampire that's why everybody wants to do
at least in that universe in the anne
rice universe is you don't you just roll
out of bed and you just look fantastic
because man wouldn't we all like to have
that yes we would like your hair looks
fantastic you don't need makeup
you just like you're not all rumpled and
like [ __ ] you have drool crusted on
the side of your face and [ __ ] like that
you just come out and be like tada like
i'm fabulous so like how awesome would
that be
that was one of my favorite things about
i know this is weird but that's one of
my favorite things about the jetsons
was you remember in the um
in the credits of the jetsons
the mom
jane yeah like when she got up and then
she would just be like wow like we all
look when we get out of bed and then she
would just like go in the little chamber
or whatever and it was like and then it
would like her hair would be perfect and
her makeup would be perfect and her
clothes would be all perfect i'm like
yeah we need that
we need that so you don't have to go
through this big [ __ ] rig roll
you know
like all the grooming and stuff that'd
be cool if you could just like go in and
be like
yeah
um zach says speaking of polanski
chinatown is one of my top ten that's
another one that we really need to
do like a matinee on maybe we should do
romeo and juliet moulin rouge in
chinatown this week
should i write that down yeah if you
want i kind of feel like those are the
ones that we should that we should do
because those are ones that i've been
wanting to do for a long time and we
just never got around to them
i've been trying to do more horror
movies but
you know
it's just kind of like i do a lot of
horror movies for my other shows so
by the way go
go
subscribe to my scare salon uh channel
and also the site the site is just
caresalon.com because there's a lot of
written stuff on there and i'm putting
like new [ __ ] up like every day i'm
gonna do two videos a week i'm thinking
about i don't know if you guys are
down with this but i've been thinking
about you know my flickers of fear show
my tomes of terror like my book reviews
and stuff i might move those over to the
other channel i mean they're still gonna
be the same otherwise but
i don't know then that way like
everything
with just me will be on that channel you
know what i mean i don't know maybe i
might not but we'll see how it's going
and i'm doing the true crime one too
i've been working on that as today as
well
so i'm hoping to have that up by august
1st i haven't made any of the videos yet
but the site is almost done
so i just need to make like a few videos
and then get that
get that going
um john smith says shame f murray
abraham didn't go on to be a bigger star
yeah i kind of feel like that like he
won the academy award i mean and
rightfully so
but
i feel like that happens like two
particular kinds of actors like they
have like this one year where they're in
this movie and i was like oh my god it
was so amazing and they win an oscar and
then you'd think that that would lead to
like larger roles but it generally
doesn't
and i'm not really sure
why that is i mean he was so good in
that i mean he's been in like [ __ ] tons
of other stuff i'm not saying that his
careers went nowhere because obviously
he was in a bunch of stuff after that
too but
i don't know i just i just kind of feel
like he was so amazing in that and he
didn't really get
maybe the career that he should have got
but
i don't know man well tom hulse didn't
and you know playing amadeus like he's
he was in kind of like indie [ __ ]
didn't what was that movie we watched
the other day that he was frankenstein
frankie yeah he was in that i totally
forgot he was in that and honestly he
was kind of probably my favorite
character
in that he was kind of a reason why he
he didn't really catch on
you know maybe he maybe behind the
scenes people didn't like him or maybe
it's difficult to work with or
maybe he wanted too much money
or yeah i mean i don't even know like
sometimes
sometimes it's that yeah i kind of feel
like maybe
the problem was i think he got so
associated with period pieces or
something playing mozart
yeah because that was such an iconic
performance that i think people had a
hard time seeing him as anything else
maybe you know what i'm saying maybe
that's what it was
so i kind of feel like that's see that
always happens if you're an actor it's a
real double-edged sword like you always
want to find like some big role and
everybody recognizes you and stuff like
that but if that's the only thing that
they
associate you with going forward
then
you're going to have a bad time because
you're not going to get like any other
roles so
like i said it's kind of like
i don't know i kind of feel like uh
jenny post your new channel on facebook
yeah i did um and it has a facebook page
too like i did is it a page or a group
yeah i did like a facebook uh page too
so
i'm gonna like i said i'm gonna try to
like post more i might like i said move
the flickers of fear stuff and
everything like to that channel as well
but
it'll probably be after giallo july
though because i'm still like working on
that tomorrow's gonna be because i know
a lot of y'all were excited about
jl of july tomorrow is going to be cat
and ninetales which is the dario argento
movie which i actually hadn't seen in
many many years and then i rewatched it
recently
but and i'm gonna do disco path because
i know somebody wanted that but all the
other ones are gonna be old ones and i'm
gonna do new york ripper too that's the
next one i gotta do i gotta record
um
slasher friends the credits for jetsons
that everyone knows is when george and
elroy
is on the treadmill and a cat appears
and he starts chasing jane stop this
crazy thing yeah i remember that one
what's the new channel it's called the
scare salon
yeah it's like a i did like a cool logo
for it it's got like a little skull with
like a little barber brush like sticking
out of it but yeah so it's gonna just be
all horror [ __ ] yeah
i need to get a camera like that
so i can cut some videos
yeah i don't make my own channel we can
hook it up to this one
i mean the thing about it is that
youtube
i'm not really sure how many channels
because i have
um well i have mini yeah you can have a
bunch of channels
well it's just kind of like because i
have this one
um i have scare salon which is my new
one i think 13 o'clock in minutes is
still up there and i still have one like
under my old name i don't even remember
what the [ __ ] is on there so the new
channel is is uh linked up directly with
this one yeah okay yeah yeah yeah it's
just another and you just go up and you
can switch back and forth the only
problem and maybe you guys can like help
me out with this instagram theoretically
will let you have multiple accounts i
think you can have up to five like under
the same thing
so on my phone
i made under the 13 o'clock one i made
another account for scare salon but when
i try to access it on my
desktop i can access
uh 13 o'clock on my desktop you have to
go
to um you have to go under like
developer tools you have to make
essentially you have to make your
desktop think that it's a phone like
that it's a mobile device okay but you
can do that you can go into developer
tools and make it look like it's a phone
and then you can
you know interact with instagram the
same way you would be on a phone
so i do that but
it'll let me switch between the accounts
on my phone but it won't let me do it on
the desktop even though i've put even
though i'm making it think that it's the
phone and i don't know why and it's
really frustrating because it's really
frustrating having to like post stuff
for my [ __ ] phone because i don't
have the artwork and all the other stuff
all the artwork is on my computer so i'm
just kind of like now i have to like
upload it to google drive and then i
have to download it on my phone and then
i have to put it up and it's a big pain
in the ass so i'm hoping that i'll be
able to put it together because like i
said i'm starting another channel too
which is going to be all true crime i'm
going to stick to all like unsolved
stuff
and i want to have another instagram for
that too
like i said i wanted to keep them all
under the same account
but i want to be able to switch back and
forth between them like easily and it
doesn't really seem that i can do that
so
maybe somebody's got an idea somebody
like i read somewhere they're like oh
download this um
this app what the [ __ ] it called it's
not slack it's uh
i don't remember what it is but they
they said okay you can download it and
it'll like link up like all your email
accounts and all your facebook and all
that kind of [ __ ] so i did that
but then i was like okay well i want to
specifically link up all my instagram
accounts it's like oh well you need to
upgrade to the professional version for
that and i was like you can't i was like
eat a dick i'm not doing that
i thought you already did yeah but i'm
waiting for some oh that's
right uh victor said i missed like two
to three months of shows yeah i mean
like i said i don't know i had that
i just had the idea like i still you
know we're still gonna do [ __ ] on this
channel obviously but
i feel like
i'm not complaining i'm just saying that
i feel like this channel
when we first started it
we were just doing one show a week we
were normally doing like paranormal [ __ ]
or
you know weird stuff
and then we added movie reviews which is
fine and then like as time has gone on
it's just kind of like all over the
place like we still do movie reviews and
all that kind of stuff but i kind of
wanted
like a separate that's why i started
doing like tomes of terror that's why i
started doing flickers of fear because i
said well i want
you know i wanted a playlist or
something like that that was still like
all horror or all
so you know just all focused rather than
just talking about whatever so i wanted
to do that but
at some point i was just kind of like
well maybe i should just start a new
channel and then put everything over
there on that because
i had like an old blog
that had all of this
like i used to write
long like movie reviews and like funny
[ __ ] like about silent movies and stuff
like that and i was like man i could
like nobody reads that it's like i could
totally use all reuse all that content
like you know or update it or whatever
or make videos out of it it's like why
let it go to waste because i wrote all
of it like a long time ago so i figured
that i would you know just start a new
channel doing all that stuff and like i
said start stuff that was more
focused i want to do
a you know horror channel that's just
all books and movies um
and mo not i might do like movie review
like
i'm kind of thinking oh well we'll do
like
i'm going to talk about one movie but i
kind of like the idea of doing maybe
like lists one thing that i'm going to
start doing on scarceline i've already
recorded one of these um but it's not
going up until later in the month is i
started doing a series
that is
i pick my favorite horror movies from
every
year since i was born so i've already
done 1972 which was the year i was born
so i'm going to do that for like every
year like every time i know it's going
to take forever but i was like oh that'd
be a good idea for like some continuing
content so i'm going to try and put one
of those up at like every few
weeks like going forward like from
august but yeah um
picture says i've been listening to
y'all since 2017 when i was delivering
dominoes in nursing school wow
i just got domino's delivered yesterday
just got a sandwich and a salad because
tom has not been cool he's been sick
still i'm sick he still are sick so i'm
barely hanging on he has not felt like
cooking or eating or anything yesterday
i think what you had two protein shakes
and that was all you had all day right
yeah and i slept almost i slept the
whole time he pretty much slept like all
day i think he slept until two o'clock
in the afternoon
and then he was just like laying around
and then i think he went back to sleep
at like 10 p.m
and
so i was just kind of like well i said
well i'm just going to order some
dominance i said i don't want any pizza
but i just wanted like a sandwich so i
had to bring me a sandwich and some side
salad but and then today i went to
publix but you had the i got you a sub
though yeah was it good yeah
yeah they always have did you eat the
whole thing the whole [ __ ] thing yeah
the whole [ __ ] thing i got i got you
a foot long i didn't get a foot long i
was because i was just gonna go i was
mad because i was like i'm just gonna
pop down to publix i was just going to
get something out of the pre-made stuff
like in the pre-made deli case because
like you know they have little
sandwiches and little salads and [ __ ] in
there and he's like oh make me a sound i
was like man now i gotta wait in line
and like also like [ __ ] got six people
in the house
[Laughter]
well that was the reason that i wasn't
gonna get a sub one they're too
fattening and two i was like man i don't
want to wait live but then i had to
i just got like a little bitty
i think it was chicken and cranberry
croissant and like a tiny little thing
of like pasta salad
so
i've had under 900 calories today no
under under 800 actually no i'm thinking
about it
so i'm doing good
john smith said speaking of tombs of
terror i found your channel thanks to
your review of house of leaves
yeah i just
i feel like i hope i did that book
justice it's really really hard to like
talk about because there's so much
to talk about and i was just kind of
like i know i went on for like almost an
hour but i was kind of like i felt like
i didn't even really cover it another
thing that i've started doing too like
on my movie reviews and my book reviews
as i've started like kind of writing i
usually have notes and stuff but i've
usually started trying to write
something out that's more cohesive like
before i actually record the [ __ ]
because sometimes i feel like if i just
have like some half-assed notes which
was what i had been doing then
you know i'm just like they're talking
and then like i finished recording then
i'm like oh [ __ ] i forgot to like say
this that and the other thing and then
i'm like well [ __ ] it i don't want to
like go back and fix it now so you know
uh yeah oracle said subscribe to the new
channel thank you thank you yeah we've
only got so like i said it's only been
up for like a few days
i'm gonna put the videos up
on wednesdays and saturdays but like i
said the website is gonna have
like new written stuff like go up every
day i already have
this whole month like one or two things
going up every day
jason s says your channel is genius well
thank you casual and upbeat you share
your interest in different kinds of
genres and entertainment yeah i mean i
think that that's kind of like what a
lot of what attracted a lot of people to
our show initially
was because that's a lot of the messages
that i got that they liked
kind of our back and forth because we're
obviously like very very different
people and we i mean we like a lot of
the same things but we like a lot of
really disparate like different things
too and have very strong opinions about
it so i think that it's kind of like a
lot of people seem to like our sort of
like interactions about that kind of
stuff zach says what's a movie
where you can't decide if you hate or
love it or book
ooh
where i can't decide if i hate or love
it
that one's a hard one usually i'm pretty
it's i'll tell you one thing it's really
really rare that i see a movie that i'm
like i absolutely hated that piece of
[ __ ]
most of the time i either liked it i
loved it or i was just kind of like eh
like i didn't bother finishing it
i feel like
it would take a lot for me to actually
like muster up
the energy
to hate something like that you know
what i mean i do hate things but i feel
like something is
innocuous
as a book or a movie which isn't gonna
like kill me or hurt me or anything i
just i i can't see getting all that
riled up about it the worst thing a
movie could be is boring that's what i'm
saying you don't hate those you're just
kind of like uh
yeah i don't hate it i'm just kind of
like yawn i have better things to do so
i kind of feel like
i don't i don't know if i've ever seen
i'm sure i have i don't know if i've
ever seen a movie or a book that i like
actively hated like this is the worst
this is like cancer on society um with
me that would be uh the last jedi
i [ __ ] hated that movie see i didn't
hate it i [ __ ] hated the last jedi
just everything that star wars
should not should never be it was and i
just i just [ __ ] hated that movie
just dumb dumb dumb
the one that was after it
was a [ __ ] show
but
there was a good movie in there it's
just that it had to [ __ ] make up for
um it was it it was so long it had to be
two movies because it had to kind of
like [ __ ]
paint over what had happened in the last
jedi
um
okay you know the you know the [ __ ]
thing with the
they go to the special planet and they
got all the damn clones and everything
i don't know well hang on i gotta pee
just okay all right well this [ __ ] then
i was telling you well no we'll tell
them
i already know i've heard you [ __ ]
about star wars a lot i already know
the little they go to that planet and
they have all those clones and then they
have the [ __ ] cloned emperor running
around on the [ __ ] chair with the
feet and [ __ ]
i'd only seen it once you know what i
meant i didn't go back to watching that
[ __ ] second time but
that actually came from a comic book
i didn't know it but that was like
something from the extent of the
universe they kind of made it canon
it was handled better in the comic book
i saw a video so we made a video about
it
on youtube
pointing out where they got that from
and it look the original story seemed
really cool it's just
it's disney you know
disney doesn't have really west you know
between me and you she's in there so
i'll talk behind her back
disney doesn't have a [ __ ] what it
takes to make star wars
the first two mandalorians are pretty
good but then disney went in there and
meddled and [ __ ]
[ __ ] up his name jean fravo he was
trying to do a really good job
but disney just can't leave alone
they're they they like to uh let's just
say they like to molest in things they
gotta put their fingers and they got to
get in there and kind of
uh uh uh they gotta they got they gotta
they gotta groom the situation you know
what i mean [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] disney
okay
i'll go to the restroom too that's good
i missed that whole thing yeah
chocolate behind your bed
what'd you say did you say something
mean about me did you say something mean
about me
it's just i can't i don't know i can't
really muster up that much i mean both
they were all right i didn't really care
that much one or the other
like i said it's not
movies don't murder my family so i'm not
really all that concerned
uh
john smith said oh actually okay this is
a good point john smith says movies i
can't decide if i hate her love
everything by wes anderson
yeah i'm kind of
i don't know i'm kind of like hit or
miss on that it's like i haven't seen
all his movies but i have seen enough of
them and i'm just kind of like i know a
lot of people really like them and i'm
just kind of like do i like that
not entirely sure
you know what i mean i don't know i kind
of feel like i'm one of those people
that
when i start watching a movie
most of the time
like within the first
five ten minutes depending like just the
whole vibe of the thing not always
because sometimes it surprises me one
way or the other but sometimes like i'll
start watching and be like okay i'm yeah
i'm vibing with this i really really
like this and it'll like suck me in i
don't have the same rule as tom has it's
like oh if it doesn't suck me in the
first five minutes like he's just bored
and he doesn't want to watch it i don't
do that i will give pretty much
everything a chance because
you know it's a movie it's a long art
form and it's just kind of like i just
want to see
i'm just interested i'm interested to
see what people come up with you know
what i mean
thank you katie happy belated birthday
tom i'll tell him when he gets back uh
for monster cat and wife oh thank you
very much that's so sweet
um
victor said i hated the last season of
game of thrones you know
i still haven't watched game of thrones
i feel like i probably should
but there's just so much [ __ ] i have to
like keep on i feel like so like
culturally bereft i just like i haven't
watched like all this big [ __ ] stuff
that's like so you know what i mean but
i just i only have like so many hours in
the day and it's like i got so many
movies to watch and i get so many books
to read and i got so many [ __ ]
i'm working on writing a book and it's
just kind of like i feel like i never
have enough time and there's just so
much and i think i've talked about this
before like every time
like when i'm doing a poll like for
patreon and i'm like okay well i need
like five movies that i can put in the
poll this week so let's see what's
available like on all of the streaming
services that i have so i scroll through
there and i'm just like ooh ooh oh
oh man and it's like oh [ __ ] i gotta
watch that oh [ __ ] yeah we should watch
that and it's like it seems like we've
done
a million movies but then there's still
like a million that i want to do and
that we still haven't done and
it just i'm just like oh my god i'm not
gonna live long enough i'm not gonna
live long enough to like watch all these
movies and like see all of these and
read all these books it's like it's kind
of bumming me out but
which is one of the which is one of the
reasons that i'm excited about like you
know uploading my consciousness into
this into a chip and like putting it in
an avatar maybe i can
actually watch all these [ __ ] movies
that i want to watch
but yeah i don't yeah i'm kind of
ambivalent about wes anderson movies i
think i saw a couple of them in the
theater
and i remember liking them okay but
i didn't really get and i'm not like if
you love them i know some people do but
i'm just kind of like i didn't really
get that i'm just like a certain kind of
people like really likes
like really loves those like really
vibes with those and you know that's
cool i get that but for me they're just
like yeah that was
cool
i don't know it's just not really
maybe it's not my thing i'm not really
sure i like them it's just not
something that i would be like really
really into
i mean here's an example of
something that we've seen recently
because and amazingly like tom was
really into this one too but when we
first started watching
the varium because like i said we had
heard about it
and i was like oh that sounds kind of
cool like let's watch that i didn't know
a huge amount about it but we first
started watching it and like within
the first few minutes of the movie i'm
like i'm really gonna dig this i could
tell like already like i just there was
just something about the whole vibe of
it and i ended up loving that movie that
was like one of my favorite movies of
that year there was just something about
and like i said and it's cool if like
you didn't like that movie or if it
didn't like hit right with you
everybody's different but that one just
like really hit me like right in the
exact right way and it's the same thing
i think i mentioned this on one of my
flickers of fear shows where i was
talking about
the movie come true
and i was like i get it if you didn't
like that movie but that movie
just it hit like all the but i was like
oh man that was like so [ __ ] good i
really really dug that movie and sensor
as well like that was another one that i
covered and there was just something
about that one that was just exactly
what i liked and i got like really
really into it and then it happens too
that like sometimes like all the horror
fans will come out and be like oh see
this one it's really awesome and then i
see it and then i'm just kind of like
like it's good but i didn't love it you
know what i mean but when i saw come
true i loved it when i saw sensor i
loved it actually when i saw x i loved
it and you guys saw that one kind of
like oscar particularly because he kept
bugging me to see it thank you very much
katie yeah
she said happy birthday dale monster
caddis yeah
but yeah i was talking about um
how much we loved vivarium yeah great
movie
yeah and like i said i get if people
didn't like it but it's original there
was just something about that one just
the whole look of it creepy like the
whole creep yeah like the whole creep
vibe of it it's just that really really
resonated with me but different things
resonate with different people like i
said i think we've talked about this
before i showed it to my buddy my army
buddy [ __ ] my everybody chaffino and he
was like what the [ __ ] was that he got
him
he got mad
he got mad that he watched it he goes he
pulled up the he he pulled up the the uh
the he pulled up the corner and [ __ ]
ran underneath the street underneath the
sidewalk yeah yeah
and he's like what the [ __ ] am i
watching
that's it it's beyond you i guess it's
beyond the old trafino he didn't get i
said dude it's happening in another
dimension man you're captive yeah it's
another dimension and he's just like
he's like no
i said it's like a friend that's so
funny to me that like some people really
don't like couldn't get it can get it
i mean to me like i said maybe just
because i've liked horror since
birth you know as long as i can remember
ever since i was a little kid i loved
scary [ __ ] so it's just kind of like i'm
very willing to
you show me a scary movie and you're
just like going out here with like yeah
we're gonna have this bizarre thing
happen i'm just like okay
i just kind of like let it happen i
pulled you into a pair pulled him into a
parallel dimension yeah that way out
they had him in a little pocket
put him in a nest
little parallel to made him raise its
child
some weird [ __ ] man
but now after that i was like that jesse
eisenberg man he he picked some good
projects he has you know the the
projects he volunteers to go on because
i saw that and then i saw um
like in the art of self-defense and i
was like yeah this guy's got good taste
yeah he's got real good time well he
very famously he was in the first zombie
zombie land also well he was also in the
second zombie yeah those are like big
corporate movies though yeah i'm talking
about these little private projects he
gets these little indie flicks he's
[ __ ] got good taste yeah because
bavarian was like an irish director i
want to say i think he was an irish
director well indie flick is real good
man
and um
jenny thought i was going to hate art of
self-defense i was sitting there
watching this in the in the movie and
i'm just slipping it on inside the
theater
and afterwards i'm just sitting there
and i'm just [ __ ] doing it i'm just
trying to find a problem with it
somewhere and she's looking at me you
know because i didn't say anything so
that move was a [ __ ] masterpiece
because you liked it oh yeah yeah
because the whole time i was looking i
thought it was hysterical but i just
like the whole time you can't tell like
because he'll sit there in the movie and
he'll just be sitting there and he
always
he always like when he's in the movie
theater he always makes noises as though
he's annoyed like he'll sit there and
he'll be like
so i always think that he's like mad
like whatever the movie is it doesn't
matter so i always think like oh man he
hates this and then i get like stressed
out but then like afterward he's like oh
man that was the best movie ever i'm
like well why were you like [ __ ] you
sounded like you were over there
reacting to what they were doing
like he sounded like you're getting like
all exasperated
he always sounds exasperated
like when he's in the movie so i never
tell i can never tell like what he's
gonna like or not most of the time i can
tell most of the time i can tell like if
i always plug those two movies he's got
something and he's always working with
that girl too
imogen poop imogene yeah imogen foods
she was in both of those movies she was
great in both those movies cute too that
was his girlfriend
i don't know if it is i think they just
work together a lot but like i said i
don't know about a lot of celebrity
gossip so it very well might be for all
i know that uh
i'm waiting or do they have a new one
out together i don't know
because if they're in it it's gonna be
good
yeah i like the two of them together
like they work really well like i think
their chemistry was really good i think
what they do is they look at those
scripts and they're like they'll pick a
really good script they don't care how
unmarketable it is because i don't think
either one of those movies are really
marketable but they're genius
you know genius you know well sometimes
the best movies are ones that well
usually the best movies are ones that
they make where they don't worry about
how much money right because if you have
to make a movie you know if you have to
make a move it makes a billion dollars
like a lot of times it'll be good like
it'll be enjoyable
but it won't you know it has to appeal
to like a broad array of tastes which
means that it's gonna just be kind of
like yeah that was that right it's not
gonna be like brilliant you know what
i'm saying which is fine it's it's you
know that's its own reward i guess and
they are entertaining but
for something to be like super brilliant
i feel like most of the time it's not
gonna be appeal to everybody
um john smith said liked horror movie
since birth what is the earliest horror
movie you remember mine was the gate ooh
i liked the gate um probably the
earliest one i remember seeing and i'd
see you guys are gonna laugh the
earliest one that i remember seeing that
scared the [ __ ] out of me and i've seen
it recently and it's not scary at all so
i don't know what my deal was was uh
children shouldn't play with dead things
and that movie came out in what 1972 i
want to say the same year i was born and
i think i saw it when i was
maybe seven
or something i think i was seven or
eight when i saw it and scared the crap
out of me but i was still really into it
that one and my bloody valentine but
that was like a couple years later hey
sly i see you're in i see you're in the
comment sections have you seen art of
self-defense with with jesse eisenberg
if you haven't seen that movie you need
to check that one out you'd like that
one
that's a [ __ ]
weird ass [ __ ] kung fu flick
okay
but it's it's it's real
it's crazy it's absurd
but it's based on the kind of [ __ ] that
really did happen
like the dojo wars the chicago dojo wars
of the 1960s with [ __ ] that like that
that was look like a vampire doing
karate
that was a real dude and he did he was
doing a lot dear mock he was doing a lot
of the [ __ ] weird ass [ __ ]
they got they killed somebody it sounds
like it it sounds like
[ __ ]
sounds like a joke man but no they were
doing crazy [ __ ] and it was [ __ ]
larping ass [ __ ] crazy
white dudes with black dudes and [ __ ]
you gotta watch those people man there's
like their their fantasies are just kind
of like get out of right
well art of self-defense is uh
not happening in the 60s but it's a
similar situation
and um
it's a comedy
but not really it's like a dark comedy a
lot of bad [ __ ] happens it's just a good
flick but see that's exactly the kind of
comedy i like
that's like it's like a [ __ ] up black
comedy and everything in the movie even
though it's ridiculous kind of checks
out to like being true like yeah that's
kind of the way warrior the army is
because be an ex-army you'll understand
it you'll understand it's about warrior
cults
in this case it's this [ __ ] dojo
cheesy ass [ __ ] ball dojo
[Laughter]
like you said it's like toxic
masculinity toxic masculinity yeah
that's what i thought was so funny about
it
that it was obviously like very
i mean it is the one scene where he's at
work and just like straight up punches
that dude in the face it's just like i
laughed
it's about
strength
and weakness okay
weak men
becoming strong and pretending to be
strong
and hurting people
it's just a weird it's a weird [ __ ]
it's not a real strength it's kind of
like an imitation strength
but but it's dangerous yeah it's very
dangerous and uh
i think that's what i thought was so
funny yeah
i know it's i get that it's not for
everybody but that was like that's like
exactly my sense of humor
so it's like when i was watching the
movie i was just like dying i thought
that was like the funniest [ __ ] thing
ever yeah but
and and the the idea that strength comes
out of weakness
because you start off weak
you become strong
and most people abuse it
and it's not a real strength
now i will say that i think the same guy
that directed art of self-defense yeah i
think he does have a new movie coming
out called duel okay but i can't
remember if jesse eisenberg is in it or
not i'm gonna have to have jesse i
wasn't bringing that [ __ ] i don't
remember if it is i remember seeing a
trailer like
like a month ago
like duel like do you d-u-a-l
like to it it's about clones okay so it
looked good like it looked weird as [ __ ]
and i was just like oh i'm here for it
like
you know you guys know i like weirdest
[ __ ] movies weirder [ __ ] movies
one of the actually one of the best
movies that just reminded me because i
was talking about
movies that came out a couple years ago
like uh like censor and come true and
stuff that i was really into one of my
favorite and this kind of goes in with
my whole giallo july thing too
one movie that i saw recently that i
absolutely [ __ ] adored was in fabric
which is not exactly a giant movie but
it is very giallo inspired i think it
came out in 2017 2018 something like
that that movie was weird as [ __ ] it's
been a haunted dress and that sounds
stupid but it's
it's pretty great like i really really
liked it i liked the whole like
aesthetic of it it's just like weird as
[ __ ] and i was really into it and it's
just like visually it was like super
cool too but yeah i loved that as well
that's probably that and sensor and come
true are probably like my favorite ones
that i've seen in the last
six months i want to say i think those
are my favorite ones and like i said
it's okay if you don't like them but
those those are the ones that just kind
of like hit me like exactly in the right
way
so you know
uh yeah john smith said a zombie movie
about the horrors of theater groups
exactly and i think that guy well the
main guy that was in it
and this
it's been a while since i thought about
that movie but i think like the main guy
that was in it didn't he also write the
screenplay i want to say and i think he
wrote some other screenplays as well
but i don't really i don't remember like
what scared me so much about that movie
because i remember seeing it
i think the last time i watched it was
probably like five years ago because i
said oh i want to watch this again
because i remember scaring the crap out
of me when i was a kid and i hadn't seen
it since then and then i'm watching it
i'm like what the [ __ ] scared me about
this movie
it's like really not scary but
i don't know i was a weird kid and i
think i've told this story before but
when i was little the two things that
scared me the most like probably up
until i was six or seven years old
were you know the song monster mash
um and you know how it has that bubbling
cauldron sound effect at the beginning
for some reason that gave me a panic
attack the bubbling cauldron sound i
don't know why i still don't know why
um and i had to leave i liked the song
but i had to leave the room like when it
came on because that used to scare me i
don't know why
and the other thing that scared me and i
actually wrote a short story about this
kind of
was when i was a kid my uncle kevin
made
um a paper mache
mask it was like a dragon's head it was
awesome actually it was like this whole
full body like dragon's head with a
tongue hanging out and it was like
glittery like he made it like and it was
glittery and it had kind of like big
[ __ ] scales and all this kind of [ __ ]
on it and it was beautiful but he kept
it in his room
at my grandfather's house and i was
terrified of that thing like i would not
even go upstairs
like i thought it was cool but at the
same time i was just kind of like i
can't go up there it'll get me i don't
know why i was like six
you know what i mean i don't know why it
scared me so much my cousin actually
like inherited it because i remember
like going to see my cousin like was
probably like 20 years ago and i was
like oh you have uncle kevin's dragon
mask that used to scare the [ __ ] crap
out of me for whatever reason i still
don't know why i don't know why the
bubbling cauldron sound scared me so
much even though the song didn't scare
me just that sound did
i don't know why it triggered some
[ __ ] weird thing in my brain for
whatever reason and that [ __ ] mask
like scared me
too um tammy says
saw a movie on to be called regression
about the satanic panic in the 1980s
with ethan hawk ooh i might have to like
check that out that sounds like right up
alley caitlin higgins says jesse
eisenberg was also in the double
another movie about clones which is okay
i mean yeah i don't think yeah i've only
seen two of his movies
like i said you should probably see the
social network because that was about
the founding of facebook
was that's actually like really really
good like the movie is really good i saw
that in theater actually um but yeah and
john smith said in fabric was great
wasn't it god i loved that [ __ ] movie
so much it was just like it was it was a
visual feast and it was just so weird i
loved it i just wanted to know what his
new newer
projects would be after um
after art of self-defense that's been
about three years now huh
yeah i think yeah what did that happen
we saw that in the theater but it was a
couple yeah i think it was 2018.
okay so 2019. so it might be four years
maybe it's 2019. okay i can't it was a
good movie
victor says does the bubbling cauldron
sound still have an effect on you no
that's why i don't understand like why
it did back then like it was extreme
like because we had monster because i
loved halloween and i loved spooky [ __ ]
and stuff like that so we had all these
halloween sound effects records and you
know monster mash and all that kind of
stuff so we had all that stuff
um
but whenever somebody played monster
masher when it came on the radio
like i would always be like
and like i'd run out of the room and i'd
run out of the room until that and i'd
be like tell me what that part's over
tell me when that part's over just it
just scared you i don't know why like
the rest of the song didn't bother me
just like
yeah
and like like i said it's just like a
cauldron bubbling yeah i have no idea
like why that stressed me out so much i
was a weird [ __ ] kid yeah that was a
weird kid but you know it was just one
of those things
yeah and the thing about it though was
that
even i mean from as young as i can
remember i just
[ __ ] scared me but i liked that you know
what i mean yeah and maybe like i feel
like a lot of 80s kids maybe had that
maybe kids nowadays have it too i don't
really know but i mean look at all of
the entertainment like for children that
came out in the 70s and 80s a lot of it
was kind of scary
but
kids like that kind of [ __ ] though i
liked that kind of [ __ ]
maybe i don't know i don't know if it's
different nowadays but back then there's
another time
yeah back then it was like wasn't this
much to choose from back then that's
true that's true
you know like a lot of [ __ ] like you
know what is that is that gum
ice cubes yeah it's gum oh yeah why you
want some yeah how much you pay for that
that's a she got a whole case a damn ice
cube's gum well yeah
that will get that one because that
one's open already
yeah it's peppermint it'll probably help
my sinuses yeah it's yeah it's strong
yeah okay
yeah i love peppermint gum
well and it's good for like if you get
hungry you just like pop it in your
mouth and then you like you feel like
you ate some you know what i'm saying
yeah so i always have those i think that
case was
nice
yeah never seen those before they're
little square ice cubes yeah well i
usually buy it in a big bag but they
didn't have that so i got that little
case which was the same price
i mean it's not you know
i like that probably a better deal
i think it was sixteen dollars for
fifteen dollars
i get that and i get
well because like i said i like to have
i'm trying not to eat all that much so
i'm i like to have things that are like
low calorie like gum
that if you get kind of hungry but i was
like oh i probably shouldn't eat right
now
you know do that so i have that and i
also got like a big five pound bag of
like hard candy that's like coffee
flavored and those are 15 calories each
so
and they're good like because you know
it tastes it's good it's like coffee but
it's kind of sweet
so you can feel like you had something
sweet without
actually like getting all the calories
you know
yeah right sore you gonna die yeah
i'm not much longer i'll be able to hang
on
well
i mean we can wrap it up soon because
it's almost two hours you did good like
okay
tammy said my son used to love watching
tales from the crypt but hated the crypt
keepers laugh we would mute the tv
during that part yeah i kind of yeah i
think i kind of feel like that's
probably the same kind of thing that was
going on i could see that because he did
have like that [ __ ] was that dude's
name
john cassier cassier whatever his name
yeah that guy that did the [ __ ] keeper's
voice
and let's see what else we got going uh
john smith said a thing that scared the
[ __ ] clean out of me as a kid was the
never repeated tv show ghost watch
oh my god
one okay i'm going to do a video on that
is it going to be this month i think
it's one that i've one that i have
scheduled for next month yeah they never
showed it again it was um
okay
what it was
can you get it
yeah you can get it now but for a long
time it was kind of like it would it
aired on the bbc
back in i think it was 92 right it was
1992
and it aired as like a christmas special
because in the uk you know they still
have the tradition of like showing ghost
stories around christmas
so they showed it
and it was kind of like a very early
like found footage
type thing
they made it like because in the uk they
had the show called crime watch where
they would come on and talk about
unsolved murders it's like unsolved
mysteries or you know or uh rescue
knight or whatever the [ __ ] the one with
um
walsh john walsh it was like that
so they had that so they did one like
that
and they made it so that it was like oh
we're investigating a poltergeist case
for hot for christmas like it's a ghost
story
and was it christmas or halloween now i
can't remember but they're kind of like
so they sent like actual people who
worked at the bbc like actual news
presenters and all that and they went to
this house and it was very clearly like
based on the enfield stuff but they
changed all the names and they changed
some of the details and stuff but
they're like yeah we sent this crew out
here and they're like oh how funny we're
gonna like it's scary and it's halloween
and we're gonna remember this yeah and
we're gonna do this thing but then like
real poltergeist [ __ ] started happening
and it was like it was really clever
like the way they did it and they didn't
tell you i mean they told you at the
very beginning hey this is fake it's
just kind of like but some people didn't
see that yeah so
people were freaking out because like i
said these were like real news
presenters and they were acting as
though holy [ __ ] this is getting out of
our control um so it was kind of genius
and like kind of ahead of its time but
man people were flipping out yeah and
like they didn't show it again after
that for like a real
world yeah it was like a war of the
worlds type situation i've seen it and
it's like it's actually like really
really good if you go back to that time
period and like think of
what must it have been like for you to
just like settle in for this show
thinking it was just going to be some
funny oh hey we're going to this
people's house and they say it's haunted
and then like real scary [ __ ] like
starts happening and they're like oh no
it's like this is real people
and i just i don't know i thought it was
like pretty realistic my dad getting
taken in by the discovery channel
about the where about the uh the
mermaids the mermaids yeah i was on the
phone with it one time you guys i
remember now
i used to never believe in them damn
mermaids
i was
[Laughter]
i was watching this show on discovery
channel and they had all these
scientists and all these doctors and
lawyers
you know
whatever they showed the history of
going all back people were seeing them
damn mermaids they even have all the
bones i was like what
yeah they're like mermaids yeah
it's showing up
and mermaids are out there
i never seen one i was out you know but
you know the stories had to come from
somewhere but you know and i said wait a
minute no no no no no
no way dad because yeah
yeah i saw it on my tv yes i don't know
they had it on discovery channel
and they had all these credentialed
scientists on there talking about it and
i don't i didn't believe it you know and
i said did they show them
no they just owned cgi of them but you
know it's all theoretical but they had
the bones
they think they're out there people's
been seeing them
i said what was the name of this program
you know and he gave me
the program and everything so i'm trying
so i'm calling jenny and i said jay look
there's something man it was something
from monster week it was a damn it was a
found footage hoax program yeah
same thing it was a mockumentary
mockumentary
and i [ __ ] i had to break it to him
so dad that was a mockumentary what's
that listen
this is a fake documentary no it was
real documentary i saw it
i had to explain it to him because he
didn't even know he doesn't even know
the genre like the concept of
mockumentary he said oh and so you
didn't and i was looking at it i said i
see it i see it now this is now dad go
over here and he says remember that girl
scientists on there and he goes yeah i
want that long hair and i said yeah says
don't you think she looked a little too
pretty to be a scientist yeah she do
look a little too pretty
that's an actress
yeah okay oh since so they're just
telling stories yeah they're trying to
make you think like it's a document yeah
okay
because it wasn't on it wasn't on
halloween when i saw it
you saw the reruns oh all right
i thought they were out there
i said no
your dad's worried about mermaids yeah
mermaids
i remember that whole that whole like
phone call yeah that was very very funny
and he he'd get on a boat and go out to
gulf of mexico you know [ __ ] him and
knuckle punch
get drunk as [ __ ]
uncle punches hot ass [ __ ] daughter
up on the front i remember i was like
about 12 13.
i was getting blistered up [ __ ] start
throwing up other side and uncle punch
goes he eat when him nutter buddies
it'll feel good coming back up
uncle punch [ __ ] with me mmm peanut
butter yeah good good good going down
then a couple hours later i was totally
immune to seasickness it didn't matter
it was like it gets it gets so bad that
it's just okay [ __ ] it it goes away
and i'm out there on the [ __ ] boat
that going
yeah
that's like so funny that's so funny he
i liked the trip just because his
daughter was
punches daughter was out on the front of
her bikini she was [ __ ] hot
she was about 16. i was about 13. yeah
all right i was like yeah all right
let's head out that way and i'm
looking take old babies yeah cheddar
yeah other people well the whole time my
dad probably
for all i know you well at least ain't
no mermaids
[Laughter]
that well it's funny because i actually
like went back after that whole debacle
yeah uh i actually went back and watched
that mermaid documentary and i was like
oh my god this is clearly fake clearly i
mean it's fun but it was clearly fake to
my dad it's just you know what i mean
it's he's thought it you know as people
as people get older they lose the
ability to [ __ ] um
differentiate
they don't understand
trolling and i don't even know because i
mean trolling is an ancient art i feel
like i kind of feel like what it is
maybe it's because you know we're gen x
i kind of feel like the generation older
that's like the boomers and stuff you
listen to authority well they well they
didn't grow up in an era where i mean
the internet we didn't have the internet
until like i was older you know what i
mean like until i was in my teens or my
my older teens
but because we saw the advent of it we
kind of like saw the culture of it like
building up around it like everything
just kind of came naturally so
everything kind of comes like everything
like internet related like memes and all
that kind of [ __ ] that that comes very
naturally to gen x and younger yeah so i
kind of feel like we have a different so
it's almost like a different mindset
like you see something you see the
mermaid document or you're like well
yeah of course good one um you know what
i mean but
like they knew that in the 1800s because
[ __ ] they were yeah
they were doing that to you that's what
i'm saying it's not just because it's
not new it doesn't mean it was renewed
it's not new if it was in the newspapers
it was a lie
i mean not always but they did the same
[ __ ] back then they just did the same
[ __ ] like within the confines of the
media that they had which is usually
newspapers my understanding some of
those some of those newspapers were just
nothing but lies i mean back then like i
said people [ __ ] about nowadays back
then they absolutely did not give one
single [ __ ]
about what was true like no one cared
about getting sued or nothing like that
they would make up made up [ __ ] because
they were trying well you have to think
too that this was a time where
newspapers was your main form of media
and it was also well so big cities had
several competing newspapers going to
war with each other so what they would
do is just kind of like well what did
they say did they say that person had
their head hollowed out like a pumpkin
okay well we have to like up that we
just make it up they just made it up
like a lot of the [ __ ] was made up so i
ran into that a lot too like when i was
researching older like true crime cases
because a lot of times they would
exaggerate like a lot of the details
because they wanted to sell more papers
than the other competing paper in the
city so they would add on all kind of
extraneous [ __ ]
so you really had kind of had a watch
and [ __ ] [ __ ] that's going on right
now
nobody's really spending any money on
news
so
the news is now asking for handouts to
the federal government
to pay them to print news so now all of
a sudden you're going to have
state-owned media
and if you think it's bad when it's just
a free-for-all it's even worse when it
becomes state-owned all right now they
just become a puppet
mouthpiece of any old [ __ ] regime or
whatever you're not gonna have any
they're gonna tell you what's true
that's what they're gonna do they're
gonna and they're already talking like
that
we are gonna tell you what's true we're
authoritative
it's not gonna be true it's just going
to be more lies it's always been lies
it's a yellow journalism it never went
away
yellow journalism and propaganda
the closer the government gets to it the
worse the propaganda gets
don't believe any of that [ __ ] danny
rowling says tom the best jesse
eisenberg film is american ultra
also starring kristen stewart uh she was
in underwater uh where he plays an
unknowing sleeper cia soldier assassin
who gets activated by his handler
because he's about to be killed that
sounds good actually what's it called
again
american ultra american altar okay yeah
check that one out sly says uh 60s 70s
80s kids cartoons were violent looking
back they were um
yeah i mean some of the ones i was going
to say like some of the looney tunes
ones i kind of feel like those were
older than 60s though because some of
the 40s from 40s and 50s
but like the ones where you know like uh
yosemite sam or porky pig or something
like that would just blow daffy duck's
face off like a shotgun like a point
blank range like [ __ ] like that are they
still showing those i don't know but uh
yeah we we always kind of like those
[Laughter]
uh tammy said when did the story of the
living pterodactyl come out yeah that's
right because remember we did a show
about that 1800s i think when early
1990s i think it was yeah i think it was
late 1800s i want to say it was like
late 19th century yeah because you kept
telling me about that and about that
and the story about like the frogs um
you know like in the rocks like the 40
in archaeology
so yeah we did we did a show about that
like a long time ago and it turned out
like the pterodactyl story for real was
just like made up
but they printed it in the newspaper as
if it was real yeah well like i said it
was like found footage like people act
like found footage is real it's new it's
not
well we've talked about that before like
[ __ ] dracula was kind of like that
too because they're like hey these are
real people's journals and newspaper
entries and stuff like that about a
[ __ ] vampire
there was that was like pretty common
back then in the victoria they also
wrote up lots of zeppelin stories
seeing gigantic zeppelins
uh zeppelins that come and
let down a ladder and the guys come down
off the [ __ ] ladders
and ask for some tea and then climb back
and then like the whole town saw it
according to the according to the
[ __ ] newspaper and it moved westward
all lies they just well like i said back
then probably worse because you could
just print whatever you want in the
paper and no one could it's not like
anyone could check no
now there was a huge zeppelin sighting
in over san francisco in the 1800s late
1800s and they said that basically what
they're describing is a zeppelin with
wings
with search lights
thousands of feet up in the air
you know
several miles long that's kind of what
they're saying
you know size of a j or a mile long
bigger than a big ship
hovering above san francisco spinning
and shining lights down and of course
the whole city sees it
according to the article
but it's only mentioned in that one
article yeah
yeah nobody else seems to be mentioning
it
because you can write the whole city saw
it it didn't mean the whole city saw it
well yeah i mean you can write whatever
the [ __ ] you want it was 1880s well like
i said nobody it's not like anybody
could check yeah
not really they're not saying it's a
they're not saying it's a ufo spacecraft
from another planet they're saying it's
a zeppelin
and that was the ufo sighting that was
the ufo of the day zeppelin because they
knew about zeppelins well that was like
the new latest like hot technology yeah
john smith says victorian trolling best
summed up in the cottingley fairies oh
my god have we ever done like a show
about that
uh that's so impressed arthur conan
doyle poor arthur conan doyle i kind of
feel like um we talked about him a
little bit like a long time ago and then
we talked about a little bit on the
spiritualism show but we did a show
about houdini
a long time ago uh busting up seances
and stuff arthur conan doyle
you would think that the [ __ ]
that wrote sherlock holmes that invented
sherlock holmes
wouldn't be as gullible as arthur conan
doyle was that [ __ ] would believe
anything yeah he was like but like he
believed in all that spiritualism [ __ ]
the fairies
were straight up they found out later on
all the all the girls had done had like
cut fairies out of a book they colored
them in like stuck them in the ground
with like a piece of wire or some [ __ ]
like that yeah ice cream yeah or
something and he totally bought it
i was just like this is like just the
simplest thing he's just simple
well he wanted to believe it yeah that's
the thing he was like well of course
they're real that's the thing he wants
they're moving you know what they were
just blowing in the wood
because they're made of paper yeah he
wanted to believe it that's why i and i
kind of feel like that's
that's why you see like stuff like like
smart people like otherwise smart people
because he was obviously a very smart
person but like falling for dumb [ __ ]
because
that's what that's what you want to
believe so you're gonna like put some
blinders on you know it's the same with
scientology a lot of those
scientologists are not dumb a lot of
them
have pretty good iqs and have
good educations that allow them to make
enough money to where
they can spend all of it on [ __ ]
scientology you know they don't want
dumb people dumb people don't really
have any money
but scientology
can get in there
and get people to give them money
because smart people have a lot of
weaknesses they have an imagination
they have the ability to reason
and all that [ __ ] can be broken down
through this process of getting
underneath your skin and what cults do
they'll be able to do things to these
educated people you couldn't do to a
[ __ ] redneck
or something oh hell no you know uh-uh
you know they just walk off from that
you know uh oh hell no ain't jesus you
know just
see the thing about it jesus is that
you know i mean it's kind of reductive
to just kind of like put it down like
intelligent dome because there's lots of
different kinds of intelligence
i mean there's certain kinds of
intelligence where somebody's like
really super good at one particular yeah
but not another but not at other things
and i kind of feel like
critical thinking uh logical thinking in
the sense that like i said you know
people that
get sucked into culture want to believe
like certain things that's a different
kind of thing that doesn't mean you're
not smart but it's like a different kind
of
it's a different
intelligence is weird i mean a
chimpanzee they're not as intelligent as
a human being
but they can sit there and just remember
they can do they can some [ __ ] better
than us yeah they can remember um like
series of numbers series of numbers and
series of [ __ ] better than a person
far better you know like many many times
better than a human
like you could
a human might be able to remember a
[ __ ] eight-digit code or a nine-digit
code a [ __ ] chip can do like a
40-digit code
just way ahead of a human
which is strange
but their brains just work differently
yeah
you know
i mean that's fascinating to me though
because like i said when you say
intelligence i'm like well what kind of
intelligence do you mean because there's
lots of different kinds
you know yeah lots of different kinds
and i'm not saying that like intelligent
people don't get sucked into cults
because they absolutely do like every
day
but
there's kind of
there's intelligence and then there's i
don't even know if i'd call it cynicism
necessarily but
critical thinking doesn't come naturally
to most people
it's something that has to be learned
and i think a lot of people don't learn
it so even if they're smart in other
ways they don't like learn it john smith
said there's that story in which arthur
conan doyle chastised houdini i remember
this for pretending to be an illusionist
when it was obvious he had supernatural
powers and it was his duty to show the
world i remember that can you imagine
that being your best friend because they
were friends i mean they had a falling
out later on being a magician you know
your magic and he's like [ __ ] i'm not
magic
it's like it's a trick yeah and he's
like look this is how i do the treatment
he said above that
what do you say about that arthritis
high a lot of times
i kind of feel like everybody back then
was
it wasn't um
what everybody was [ __ ] on you could
get your hand on anything back then yeah
it wasn't illegal not usually so it was
just kind of like which i had no problem
with that they're [ __ ] all that
prohibition is just [ __ ] uh pain in
the ass got so many people killed
so many people behind bars let those
[ __ ] get high it's no skin off
my nose as long as they don't [ __ ]
hit me in a car i don't know i'm happy
yeah that's what i'm saying i'm just
like yeah don't let them like [ __ ]
drive or nothing like that but like i
said it's the same kind of same thing
without restrictions that you have with
alcohol yeah just control all that [ __ ]
trying to keep it away from kids i have
yeah i don't [ __ ] have absolutely no
problem with that the same the same [ __ ]
that applies to alcohol just apply it to
all the drugs across the board i'm
totally fine and here's the thing that's
not a newfangled idea people think well
the world would fall apart no it's a way
it always was it was like that in the
[ __ ] 1700s the 1800s the most of the
1900s that stuff didn't didn't really
become real hardcore illegal until like
the 80s when i was a little kid with the
crack epidemic that's really when they
[ __ ] got serious about it it was
illegal before that but they wouldn't
really do much to you
you know [ __ ]
lsd was around and weed was around you'd
be lucky to do a [ __ ]
a week behind bars
you know for
selling it or something but they just
tried
as soon as they as soon as they made it
[ __ ] as soon as they started saying
well we're going to lock you up for
[ __ ] 10 years 20 years and all of a
sudden the [ __ ] got super valuable and
they started killing each other over it
and the dea drug enforcement agency told
them that they would that that would
happen i mean they said don't do that
there is just no reason no reason for it
uh and in the 1800s and in the 1900s
they had something called the right to
bliss
where it was your right as a human if
you wanted to get high then there you go
get high that's all that's your body
that's your body like i said as long as
you're in your own house you're not
giving it to your baby or something like
that um i have absolutely zero problem
with it no zero problems it's totally
unamerican to uh crack down that hard on
that [ __ ] you just want to keep it up
and it blows up in your face blows up
your face gets worse and then all yes
have regulations yes just like you do on
alcohol yes don't let people drive on it
don't let people give it to children
blah blah blah you you know but we have
all that in place yeah you can control
all that and you can
kind of make money and it saves a lot of
lives it even saves [ __ ] cops lives
now you don't have to not even have cops
go out there trying to enforce
unenforceable laws getting killed behind
it and it would stop the rise of all
those [ __ ] nasty ass cartels down in
central and south america they're doing
a lot of gang violence yeah i'm saying
which is kind of like and they're
killing each other down there in the
south over these over these worthless
drugs really that were just made more
valuable than gold from these
and they had their hands and they wanted
to make money on it if you asked me they
wanted to make money cia and to be
honest i kind of feel like
making things illicit
makes it more attractive
yeah to teenagers and like certain kinds
of people so people are gonna like do oh
it's like i'm not allowed to drink i'm
not allowed to do this and that but i
kind of feel like if it's not that big a
deal then most people probably wouldn't
give a [ __ ] about it i grew up in brazil
well part part of my time i grew up in
brazil and um
you'll find out that [ __ ] peru
bolivia
and all those places that had cocaine
they always had that they always had
cocao
and it was always available to them and
it was always cheap and they never
really abused it because they didn't
really care much about it if they felt
sick they would go take cool cow or or
if they
um they'd snort cocaine every now and
then but there's no real reports of like
[ __ ]
hardcore addiction
they just
and if they did get addicted it didn't
really matter because it was only a few
pennies and a match box of it was like
30 cents
when i was you know [ __ ] knows kid
there
i should be worth thousands here but
down there was like 30 cents yeah i mean
i mean it's like well if you want more
just go buy some more it doesn't cost
anything
you know [ __ ]
it wasn't you're gonna go kill anybody
over it
yeah i just i think yeah some people
will [ __ ] up their whole lives over
because some people have that kind of
personality but like with alcohol but
it's like that with alcohol too and
that's legal right so i'm just i'm not
saying that's good i'm just saying that
some people are going to do that no
matter what you do yeah so it's a little
bit more out a little bit more it's
easier to get hooked on it but it's also
easier to walk away from if you ask me
you just you can't get too deep into it
but uh
the problem with it was always
the crime that it was around it and the
and the money that was always the
problem and that was something
artificially placed on it it wasn't the
wasn't the
the the compound itself the cop had
itself wouldn't and it was considered to
be a rich man's drug in the 80s only
rich people were doing that well yeah
that was like the yuppie drug yuppie yup
i remember that yeah
because man nobody could afford it it
was like thousands of dollars yeah
then they would turn it into crack and
that would become like the the poor
man's version of it
uh which because they're like hey we're
diversifying yeah now they would say
that well you get more out of it for
them i don't think so i think it's
yielding the same it's just somehow
making it
more powerful but only in the short term
that's what i'm saying yeah it's the
same high but it happens like in a
faster area in a shortened period of
time right it was always looked down
upon from the people that snorted
cocaine to just to smoke crack because
you poor yeah yeah nobody likes anything
that's associated with the pores right
but here there's gonna be a blow there
you go yeah yeah it's the same [ __ ]
you're right yeah it's the same [ __ ]
yeah
you know
it's just i don't know i always thought
that was very funny because like i said
the 80s they were very very into oh
cocaine was very like the high-end kind
of drug it's like um crack is no
different
you know they just didn't like it
because it was associated with poor
people and we're in florida okay
the florida [ __ ] the skyline of south
florida was built on [ __ ] cocaine
without that cocaine trade there would
be no miami as you know it and everybody
knows it that was during the old miami
vice era because south florida really
wasn't america as you know it was south
florida was always like central america
very much it was like pirate had a
piratey feel too she was quick yeah yeah
i could squeak
around well i wasn't sure i was just
yeah
it's uh
you know each
each state was in it in its uh
in its separate situation and uh you
know we've we've recommended some good
series one of the best ones because is
on netflix called cocaine cowboys and
talks about
how how they did that how they got all
that stuff in here
at least one of the main
organizations that did it um
but man the [ __ ] government the state
governments were involved in it too
because those guys would go to [ __ ]
prison and get sentenced for 10 years
and then [ __ ] two or three years
later you find out that dude gets
[ __ ] arrested into traffic stop
they're waiting aren't you supposed to
be in prison well they'd let him out
through the back door [ __ ] years ago
they would lock those dudes up and let
them right back out and then nobody knew
that they were out on the street
because they had the money
one of those times the guy tells the
story he said look
he gets pulled over by the cops and he
goes in the trunk
because he's what's in the trunk and he
goes what do you say he says couple keys
to cocaine and about a million dollars
once you couldn't take it let me roll
okay i went back there and opened it guy
got a cop card took off okay let's go
it's like we got more
yeah they would forget whole [ __ ]
pallets of money
that's right i forgot about that yeah
because they would like an old house and
then they'd move and then yeah they'd
ran all these little oh yeah and we'd
leave a few million dollars under there
yeah he left [ __ ] like 10 million
dollars in a pallet up in the [ __ ]
must be nice they forgot about it
yeah what's in the trunk
a couple keys of coke cocaine and a
million dollars couldn't take it
let me out of here
i won't say a word [ __ ] dude walked
back there took that [ __ ] and [ __ ]
throw it in the coffee parties party it
complains at night
camp guy said i'm more of an alcoholic
and a pothead getting under control in
my older age
i never really i'll bend all that into
pot
like i know a lot of people like it but
the few times i've done it it's like
i don't like it
maybe i shouldn't get the right [ __ ]
maybe that's what it was
it's supposed to like chill you out
right like that's kind of like why a lot
of pot that's kind of like why
but it
generally just made me more anxious
which man i don't need there's no engine
i don't need that [ __ ] i'm already
anxious and paranoid enough as it is
yeah i don't need that i don't need that
[ __ ]
highlighted thank you
um
jason says i understand heroin was
introduced to australia from american
soldiers on leave from the vietnam war
that's probably right
well i mean heroin was legal
it was in medicines and stuff yeah
until like the early like the first half
of the um
20th century what happened was is that
um
during the vietnam war a bunch of
illicit trades started happening
the us army and the generals that ran
the us army
would uh request all kinds of supplies
to use an american bases
things like refrigerators and household
goods and [ __ ] they would put inside
there to do so soldiers could do laundry
the way they would do is they would
order more than what they needed
and
the [ __ ] that was excess they would sell
it to the vietnamese on black market
and they'd pocket the money
uh the army would lose track of it but a
lot of times they didn't care
and they would even like bring in things
like motorcycles japanese motorcycles
they'd bring them in like they were
going to use them for scout bikes
but then they'd sell some of them they
sell through the back door it was a real
the vietnam war was a real way of
[ __ ]
if you were a general making a lot of
money
and people all throughout the supply
chain
were involved in black market activities
well uh
they've never really been able to nail
it down but it seems that
part of the
north vietnam war effort against the
united states
was to get heroin
into the bloodstream of american
soldiers as like a bio weapon to try to
get as many of them as addicted as
possible to cause a lot of trouble back
in the united states
and it could have been
that the cia also realized that they
could do that also and profit off of it
because drug money is black money
and uh you can't trace it so you can
spread it around throughout your friends
you can make sure certain people have
enough money to [ __ ] run for office
and all kinds of crazy [ __ ] that they do
so i think kind of like
in terms of government corruption
drug sales are a [ __ ] very lucrative
way of [ __ ] gaining power
because
it's hush it's it's it's black funds
it's untraceable
it's easy
easy to make
and uh
if you trade in it it's kind of like
you're
now there's like a blood oath an oath of
silence between the the people so
they can't rat on each other because the
the because what will come up is that
drug money
so it makes a lot of sense that
intelligence agencies be interested in
it
and
a lot
there's just a lot of stories you know
what i mean that
privately owned or cia owned [ __ ]
air [ __ ] what airlines have been
doing weird [ __ ] with
selling drugs in order to make buy
missiles to sell it to the [ __ ]
contras and [ __ ]
fun [ __ ] to get like the iran contra
scandal you know i think this [ __ ] goes
way back
it just makes sense that they'd be doing
that
because other other nations do it so i
don't see why ours wouldn't be doing it
north korea
does it explicitly
north korea manufactures and deals drugs
most of it methamphetamine
and their intelligence agencies the ones
that [ __ ] peddle it
through fishing boats that are owned by
their intelligence agencies
dan michael says i want jenny and tom to
review
that's that snake movie i saw that i saw
it when i was a kid but i haven't seen
it
that's an underrated film and relevant
given our current situation you know
what i was just thinking about
that movie the other day
i don't know why i was watching a video
about some other movie and they brought
up that movie but i think in the uk
please forgive me if i'm wrong but i
think in the uk it was called snake
because we can't just call it you know
can't just call it yes yeah
well it's lots of s's i don't know about
it i remember seeing that as a kid i saw
it as a kid too wouldn't that guy run
around killing people with uh
rattlesnakes
i thought he turned into a snake okay
turns into a snake in the end yeah i
think so i mean it's been a long time
since i've seen it
oscar says i've seen a net where a girl
thinks that
some girl thinks that she killed some
dude because she slept with him or
something
[Laughter]
that right we've all been there no i
don't know okay i don't know i don't
remember i don't remember and then
the cops was telling her that no it
wasn't because you slept with him it was
because he got bit by a snake or
something like that remember
the snake that was in your vagina
snake bit him while they were having sex
or something yeah the snake that was in
her vagina yeah went in a vagina
don't eat the batters come on let me
write my own movie
[Laughter]
it's like vagina dentata but it's like a
whole other thing in there by the way if
you haven't seen that movie teeth you
should probably see that
um
tim michael said that movie bothered me
a lot and i thought it was very little i
haven't seen it a long time i noticed
though that shutter
just recently added
alligator which i think came out in 1980
that movie also scared the crap out of
me when i was a kid but i haven't seen
it since then so i kind of want to watch
it again
american military 100 says as kids what
did each of you want to be when you grew
up i wanted to be a p40 tomahawk he
wanted to be a plane you want to be an
airplane yeah he told me that before
yeah he wanted to be an airplane i want
to be airplane here i wanted to be well
when i was little i wanted to be um a
veterinarian okay and then
when i figured out that i'd have to put
kitties to sleep yeah i was like yeah i
don't know i don't do that anymore um
so then i wanted to be an archaeologist
so yeah i actually wanted to be an
archaeologist but i've wanted to be a
writer since i was little so at least i
kind of did that but i think mostly i
wanted to be an archaeologist so there's
that i wanted to be a p40 tomahawk
one of the ones with the flying tigers
with the [ __ ]
mouth painted on it
mercenary [ __ ] p40 tomahawk
yeah
like only a little boy would want to
grow up to be like did you actually want
to be a real thing or i wanted to be the
airplane
no but i mean
later than that like did you actually i
don't remember after that it's the first
thing i remember is i wanted to be an
airplane
it's a lot better
how'd that work out for you didn't work
out
well maybe someday when you can download
your consciousnesses so you can upload
it into an airplane you can you can have
your dreams come true yeah chuck tingle
write stories about me
boyfriend airplane and his abs
well he'd have to um i feel like that he
that he would have to pound you in the
butt at some point
by my p40
boyfriend with abs
pounded it while he pounded in himself
by his pounded butt and like and i kind
of there have to be a dinosaur in there
dinosaurs yeah a billionaire being
watched by a billionaire a sexy
billionaire
eating caviar
oh chuck tingle jack tango he's a
master of iraq i mean we've like talked
about him before but if you guys are new
here please go check out
chuck dingle
uh he writes erotica
well it's all kind of everything he's
open to anything pretty much um but his
titles just go to his wikipedia page and
just read just the titles with just the
titles and you will just die [ __ ]
laughing i mean it will just like
[ __ ] cheer up your whole day
yeah i mean he writes they're not like
novel novels they're like short stories
but he like publishes them
and he has a real thing about
well dinosaurs um
planes unicorns yeah yeah um what's the
other thing that he has a big thing
about
i know there's like a lot of
uh you know not like non-organic like
like not in the ship
did he do ship ones i kind of feel like
planes were the most important thing
did he i think he did some bigfoot ones
too maybe yeah i think he did some
bigfoot ones
but zach have you ever thought of your
boyfriend you ever wanted a boyfriend
that was an airplane
i mean
his
i don't know who he is and i and i love
that he just stays mysterious like his
bio is fake
it's got a picture of a karate dude and
it's like it's not even a picture it's
like a drawing
yeah like
you know what i mean so he like doesn't
even but he writes all his own stuff he
does his own thing and it's just kind of
like
i mean there's so many good titles i
think we did that on the show like a
while back like pounded in the butt by
my own butt yeah is probably like the
classic but then like he went on to do
like sequels to that like that book got
really popular so then he was like
pounded in the butt by my book pounded
in the butt by my own butt and then like
it just went on this endless recursion
and it was just like so every single
time every now and then like if i'm a
bad mood i'll go to the wikipedia like
the chuck tingle wikipedia page and
because he puts new [ __ ] up like all the
time and like read all the new ones and
they're just like oh my god they're
hilarious and honestly like if you guys
um
i subscribe to uh dominic noble's uh
youtube channel and he does something
called lost in adaptation he does other
things too but he does lost an
adaptation where he compares uh books to
movies like the movie adaptations
and he actually did a video that was
called is chuck tingle a good writer so
he went through there and like read a
lot of his stuff and that video is like
super funny and he's like yeah he he
actually is a really good writer like
they're actually like really funny and
like really clever and stuff
um because i've always kind of i just
never got around to it you know what i
mean
i think there's a podcast
what the [ __ ] is it called it has a name
that's kind of like a chuck tingle title
like pounded in the butt by my own
podcast i think that's what might what
it might be called but they
their whole podcast is they read
chuck tingle stories to one another
and i keep meaning to like go listen to
i think it's called pounded in the butt
by my podcast but i could be wrong i
think that's what it's called
but
yeah they just go around and do that and
like i just keep meaning to like go read
some of his stuff because the titles
them were just like so so funny that
dude like really [ __ ] knew what he
was doing he really carved out a niche
and
and everybody like knows who chuck
tingle is
so
he's doing something right like nobody
knows what he looks like or i think he's
done a couple interviews but i've never
like seen him in real life
okay
american military 100 says women make
great archaeologists because they're
good at digging up [ __ ] from the past
that's because we don't forget anything
that's why that is
um john smith said i wanted to be
indiana jones after studying archaeology
university i fought considerably less
nazis than i had been led to believe
yeah i mean you know
i think that's probably i don't know i
think i wanted to be an archaeologist
you know when i wanted to when i started
wanting to be an archaeologist in school
like in elementary school we did a
project
where
they put me in uh
what they call it like the gifted
classes right like in fourth grade
so there were two
gifted classes it was just like two
teachers and it was like a big classroom
but it was separated by like a wall and
we kind of knew each other and switched
back and forth like with the teachers
and whatnot so what we did
was each
class
we had to get together
and come up with a whole entire
civilization like you had to come up
with like an ancient civilization come
up with technology the money everything
you had to come up with everything like
that and then you had to make the
artifacts
and then you had to bury them
and then the other class had to dig them
up
and describe what our society was like
from what we buried you know what i mean
and i think that was what made me want
to be an archaeologist because that was
so fun i mean like i said that i still
remember that like all the time so any
of y'all are teachers out there that
might be a good idea if you haven't done
that because i still remember it like
this many years later that was like a
super super fun project i don't even
remember like what our ancient society
was but
but yeah we came up with like coins and
like papyrus we did all kind of [ __ ]
like we made all the stuff and then
buried it and then they had to dig it up
and like tell us what our society was
like so i thought that was kind of cool
uh so i said jenny have they ever made
sequels to any of uh m night's movies
i don't think so i mean other than
the trilogy like unbreakable
split and glass
i guess that kind of counts
but
other than that
victor said i wanted to be a physician's
assistant in high school but i became an
rn 20 years later so that's like kind of
close you know
jason said you must have studied english
and excelled with your vocabulary i'm
not sure if you're talking to me or tom
but no it had to be you well i was
always i'm i read a lot and i'm also
i've always been a big vocabulary nerd
even when i was a kid i love words and i
love language and i always love that
kind of stuff and like i said as soon as
i learned to read when i was two and
i've like read everything i'd get my
hands on since then
and i'm about getting ready to give out
you lasted longer than i thought you
would yeah two and a half hours
yeah i mean you did good i'm gonna shut
it down you gotta get it you're gonna go
to sleep yeah i'm gonna start getting
ready to go yeah
i take a shower and everything yeah i
don't know if i can stay awake much
longer
i mean it's only 8 30 but like i said
you're you're sick yeah
all right so i mean like i said we'll
see you guys around we went longer than
we thought we would yeah all right so
thank you everybody for dropping by
thank you for super chats and hanging
out with us this friday evening we're
back again on sunday evening talking
about uh a movie we don't know which one
yet because it'll be one that we watch
tomorrow night probably
so
everybody come back on sunday and hang
out with us again
and we will see you guys next time
bye